nice call come cyberpunk there's just
some memes that just like transcend time
harambe i still laugh at ugandan knuckle
memes man
that will never not be funny to me
i showed joey that i slammed my penis in
the car door i don't understand
it's not about understanding it half the
memes right that's how it always starts
though you don't understand the meme
when you first get introduced yeah but
you you understand it
through a weird repetition and
kind of mutual
respect of not really understanding what
the [ __ ] is going on right it's kind of
funny but like you know most memes is
like you know you can change it up a bit
you know you can make a derivative i
don't know how much you can derive
you'll be surprised it's like a whole
steamed ham's thing right that gets
that's true that got like it it can be
pushed as much as it wants to by the way
welcome to this episode of the trash
taste show i don't know what episode
wrong not that we say this is a tragic
show
i guess we just like found ourselves in
a topic before we even like started
started the show welcome i'm your host
connor with the boys joey gone call this
segment nice [ __ ] yeah in the in the
time no no we'll there we'll go
because like
like going back to the memes i just like
i don't understand why i find things
funny anymore like i just some sometimes
like i don't know why bass boosted
things are funny but like it just it
just appears in them sometimes so i just
like laughed i think we're slowly
breaking down the human psyche and the
human consciousness and what what is
objectively funny and for some reason
seeing an orangutang and and some men
going up oh stinky seems to always make
me laugh and i can't tell you why
there's no deeper meaning i'm just
[ __ ] stupid and i've been hacked by
this system that somehow works against
me it's just like the perfect science of
just like the right noises and the right
images you know it's bad when i could
show that to a five-year-old and they
would be unamused but i'm there just
pissing myself like like crying laughing
and it's like what has happened have we
been hacked in a way that like allows
our brain to revert to like one years
old and find things funny because i
don't know anymore i don't know i just i
feel like the internet's just like
broken our sense of humor like why is
the peak of internet comedy just
perfectly cut screams like that that's
that is just like never not i know but
why is this so funny like i hear it i
hear a scream i i sleep if you cut it
just once like a millisecond in it's
[ __ ] like comedy because imagining
the disaster is way funnier than seeing
a disease
like it's like you know you've probably
seen a lot of videos right where there's
like punch lines where people use like
massive explosions yeah like the
punchline yeah but you never think like
uh so like what was that explosion
was that uh
what was blowing up people died yeah
like you know you're like explosion
gabriel you know yeah
stuff is way funnier when you don't have
when you can imagine what happens that's
true in some aspects right like what do
you think is a meme that will just like
you'll find funny in five years any wii
sports meme for me like the moment that
music starts playing i'm i'm like before
the joke even starts the moment i hear
the music it's already fine i'd like to
think when i'm 50 years old that there's
somebody i can go to and i'll be like
what's nine plus ten
and then i'll be like
twenty-one
yeah the same way that my parents
mentioned some weird 60s bbc show that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know that spotted thing yeah
this i'd like to think that's what it's
going to be like you know yeah or
someone you know they'll be like so no
head and i'm like 16 i'm like pissing
myself
i i i i we're in this weird time where i
i think humor is going to be so [ __ ]
in like oh yeah i mean it's [ __ ] month
by month let alone what it's going to be
like in like one or two years of all
humans there's gonna be like some morse
code jokes or something yeah probably
you know yeah
we're just gonna
just [ __ ] pierce ourselves it's gonna
be like visual like uh what is it
braille
yeah and then he said and it's like just
braille on the screen we're gonna be
like pissing it and it's gonna be like
that's gonna be that just sounds like a
hilarious meme that could yeah
this is where memes are going bass
boosted braille
[Laughter]
the idea that just sounds hilarious
and it's weird because being friends
with someone like chris right is that
where chris is just on the chris is in
the weirdest spot i think because i've
shown memes to chris where chris will
break down laughing yeah and they're
absolutely stupid but i've also shown
him memes where his boomer side comes
out right
what is this what is this nonsense why
is there flashing noises and deep fried
what is that what do you know what i
mean like chris is in that really
interesting spot where he's like chris
can be a boomer when he wants to be a
boomer but he also enjoys gen z here
yeah that's true and uh i find i find
that really interesting
because i'm i'm totally like i'm my
humor is so [ __ ] now yeah i only laugh
at stuff when it's like bass boosted and
farting noises
because because
i i like like
i feel like i'm a child
yeah yeah i i feel that because i it's
gotten to a point where i don't know why
i find the things i do funny i just know
i find it funny and there's no like
formula to it there's there's no there's
nothing i can break down to be like ha
ha that was why the punch line was funny
you know you can't explain half the
meaning yeah the problem is it's if you
have a favorite comedian you can be like
watch their stand-up special yeah if i'm
if i find like
i base boosted uh daffy duck slamming
his penis in the car door with crap of
the rapper there how the [ __ ] do i begin
to explain what i'm into just send a
youtube away
trust me this is 10 million views
here's the problem with sending people
weird-ass memes like that it's like and
i've had this because i've been on the
i've been on the receiving end of me i
think everyone has i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah
and uh it's just this we've turned
comedy into this weird kind of niche
where it's like
it's it's like the equivalent of liking
some weird german techno bend now and
it's like that's what that's what comedy
is now because to get like a lot of the
most funniest memes to me is it takes
like 10 layers of memes
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's it's
something that if you're not invested in
this one
like one meme aspect then you're not
just you're just not going to get the
meme because just going
the joke of the meme is like a reference
to another joke and another meme and so
on and so forth so it's like what the
[ __ ] is this coffee hold on
does your coffee taste weird what does
it taste like
what's wrong with it tastes like coffee
what kind of is it instant coffee
no it's not oh it's very oh what the
[ __ ] coffees
usually makes is it really that's some
that's some bass boosted coffee yeah
this is what i've described as a crunchy
coffee
what the [ __ ] it tastes stale yeah did
the nespresso let us down what's what's
going on is it is it the milk it's the
betrayal
get the operation send in the presses
find out what happens
that's funky like i just don't bother to
try and keep up with memes anymore just
because like it's like i already thought
the [ __ ] ugandan knuckles meme went
by so goddamn fast and now i've realized
that uganda knuckles sticking around for
a month it's like a feat of
accomplishment for me i mean i mean i
still find you can get into knuckles
yeah i think five years ago
it's even quite different from how memes
are now yeah now
i feel like okay five years ago we had
memes and we had like three or four that
were pretty big
you wouldn't really hear about other
memes but now there's always like 10
memes going on at once maybe one of them
will kind of get somewhat mainstream
yeah yeah and even then i don't even
mean mainstream like normal audiences i
mean like like on the internet the
twitter sphere yeah yeah yeah yeah
because there are so many memes like if
you ever watch uh lesson and beam
culture do you watch that channel nah
guy just discusses memes and there's
like every day there's a new meme yeah
but most of these memes live and die in
the week and i don't consider that yeah
no like if this is a niche thing that
gets used a little bit in some
communities and doesn't really take off
i'm like yeah there's you don't really
need to keep up with this because it's
it's it's it's scarcely anything to to
give a [ __ ] about yeah find out why
because we're using almond
not soy milk no no this doesn't taste
like almond milk no i use almond milk
with my coffee that's that's almond i
bought the coffee that tastes weird is
it i think it's i think it's the
combination of the almond and the coffee
probably yeah i mean like if there are
some memes that you see and you're like
this is gonna die off within two days
yeah because i feel like if a meme is
easily too easily replicated that like
your mom could do it then it's not a
good meme you know what i mean also i
feel with like some memes it's like okay
the like a video with like 10 million
views pops up it's like cool that went
viral but it's like you can't do
anything else with it yeah so it just
ends up being this one video that has a
lot of views isn't that yeah it gets
forgotten over time i think a perfect
meme right is one meme when you
initially watch or discover it you think
this is [ __ ] stupid yeah and then
third time you're like okay have you
witnessed a perfect meme yet as the
media i think vocabulary does that quite
a lot like the word like buzzing yeah
yeah i
i actually despised it when i first
heard it yeah somehow it just grew on me
yeah now i find it hilarious i don't
know why i can't stop saying it like
deez nuts yeah like these nuts is not
funny like scientifically speaking
decent is not funny
i will laugh every goddamn time i'll
find any opportunity it's one of those
memes where you you you laugh and you
like hate yourself for life yeah yeah
you know what i mean it's like dabbing
yeah it's it's the modern equivalent of
whipping yourself
mentally
yeah
you have to schedule a better help call
after this
i feel like a lot of a lot of memes now
are also like platform dependent like
there are like so many like tick-tock
trends and tick-tock memes that i like
are massive on the platform but like we
don't we don't like get exposed to it at
all and feel like it's only like the
super if like it's a super super big
meme if it like goes off of the tiktok
platform and you see it on twitter or on
like youtube as well is is japanese tick
tock good
no because because right and i know
good i'm going to say this right i'm
going to say this
i'm going to say this right now right
before people [ __ ] accuse me yeah be
like oh this is what the content gives
you blah blah blah i downloaded tik tok
right yeah fresh account yep
first thing i open it right so it knows
i'm in japan it's automatically japanese
it's automatically
what do you think comes up and i'm
scrolling for a while what do you think
comes out um well my experience yeah
from my experience it's just a lot of
like japanese girls dancing god damn it
that's all it was yeah that's all it is
literally japanese women right yeah and
yeah they're very beautiful very
attractive yeah not even dancing just
like moving their arms they just like
and they normally have
they are normally
they normally have um assets that are
bigger than normal yeah and
that was all it was i scrolled through
like 50 tick tocks and maybe out of the
50 i i i didn't pause any of them i'm
just scrolling brand new account nothing
all it knew was that i was probably male
i'm guessing getting that from the app
store yeah yeah and
that's all it was yeah like you'll enjoy
this type of content or a japanese male
and i was just like
don't get me wrong there is a time and a
place for this yeah i don't want this
yeah this is not what i want i want to
see the means i'm not the kind of person
all right i'm i am i don't know if this
is like a
[Music]
i don't want to see women i don't want
to see [ __ ] that is trying to make me
horny when i'm not horny right if i want
to watch stuff like that i'm just going
to go and watch porn
it's very obvious what audience that am
i allowed to say that that's like women
just dancing and showing off boobs i
mean it's always it's been like that
since the beginning of probably time i'm
fine with that content yeah but i don't
want that most of the time yeah i mean
there's
so much of that kind of content you can
consume
it's the same reason why you know
everyone hated the old remember when
like youtube went through this epidemic
of the reply girls yeah where it was
just you know girls you know with scans
you know obviously i i you know have
absolutely nothing against people who
want to make that content no exactly uh
you know i support uh all that stuff and
any sex workers you keep doing what you
want to do man i wish there was more
protection around stuff like that
obviously this isn't very different
but it's just for me personally most of
the time when i see that stuff i i'm not
the audience they're trying to appeal to
because i don't want to that doesn't i
don't see that stuff and i'm not like oh
this is the content i want to see right
well you're also not a horny teenager
anymore right right to me it's like as
someone who is 25 um i you know i'm
doing my own thing what not to me when i
see a girl dancing as a content creator
i'm just like okay what am i what am i
following for here yeah what am i
if i if i want to follow this cradle
what am i what am i coming back for yeah
yeah to watch them dance
like when it's not even difficult it's
like you're like 50 year olds
they do this [ __ ] same thing every
time right they just go like this
yeah
it's like your 50 year old on at a
wedding you know yeah it's just it's
just the bare minimum movement and it's
like this is dancing right right
this conversation respect me sounds so
sexy and i'm not trying to be i don't
know it's just it's not it's not the
content we personally watch
that's that's not even like the worst
kind of like likes
like the
the i don't know what the genre is but
like the sleaze bait or whatever i don't
even know what the genre is like i've
like i remember seeing it's obviously
sexual and it's going to appear and
anyone like who sees that video and says
it's not sexual it's a complete [ __ ]
it is absolutely who you're appealing to
i mean it's it's very obvious that like
at least in japan and i've actually with
the rest of the world too that like the
main demographic of tick tock is like
teenage boys and girls right so
obviously
what what are teenage boys going to
enjoy sorry andrew i don't trump jesus
that kind of sleeps because i remember
like the other trends that i saw on tik
tok was um it was like
girls who are obviously you know
very confident and uh you know trying to
uh know what was it was i can say it was
girls
that had this audio that played which
was awesome no no no no no it was like
that was a good one if we had 24 hours
with me alone and i couldn't say no
what would you do
with that one yeah
and i'm just i'm just like like
most of the memes i've seen of that are
like parodies of that but that just
means that there are enough people doing
this unironically yeah to to like well
you're already in the first place right
that's why like it's been parodied so
much because it is so saturated and it
is such it's baked it's such it's such a
sleaze for you right you know and um i
this is a new coffee yeah i always give
this a taste coffee game trash table
coffee cake
fresh cheese coffee
is it battle still tastes funny
i don't know what's happened there's
something offensive i'm not offended but
i'm like come on man just because i i
log on the platform you've got to show
me this [ __ ] yeah yeah at least at least
give me something else to look at so you
can kind of figure me out
give a little bit of variance right in
the context why are you gonna what are
you gonna assume what i'm into man like
yeah she's beautiful good for her i'm
glad she's killing i'm glad she's got 20
million views every goddamn second good
for her why did you assume i was into it
no but that's the thing right it's like
i i wouldn't even be mad if it was just
you know popping up every now and then
right it's like yeah of course you know
it has to appeal to that demographic but
like yeah i had the exact same
experience when i opened it it was like
49 out of 50. yeah which is a different
girl i'm not excited i want to be like
headline
man gets mad that woman is dancing
like that's not it but also like a
little bit of variance doesn't hurt
anyone right it just means like you the
algorithm hasn't been tailored for you
exactly exactly
but that's that's just like that's kind
of sad that that's what it was like that
if if you were a new user in japan yeah
and i assume they know my age and maybe
my my gender well it just it just means
like our
algorithmically yeah that is the content
that's kind of cool that works
apparently and i'm guessing it's because
there's a certain age range and a
demographic that the algorithm puts you
in and they're just like this person
wants to see
this kind of content yes you want to see
you want to see horny content we got you
right and i mean it's it's it's it's
everyone knows sex sales and it's always
been that like that since the beginning
of now i just very much like my horny
separate from my my life yeah
i like it
hentai right and i can i can just be
like nice but i don't feel anything
towards it but when i'm like all right
i'm now i'm gonna jack off then i'm like
all right what do you think i'm jacking
off to everything i like oh no no no no
no no no
i'm just like i'm scrolling through
no like i don't know yeah no but i'm the
same right it's like i don't like all
these like anti-picks on twitter because
i'm [ __ ] feeling horny i'm just like
oh that's cool artwork i i think i don't
know really this why why is it because
when you see hentai you're like you're
in you're unoffended by it but sometimes
you can see someone uh trying to be sexy
and it could be annoying i don't know
because you're like well i i think it's
the difference between just someone
trying to be sexy and someone who's done
put art into it right because yeah i i
think i think the same way except when i
see like a [ __ ] amazing cosplayer for
example right i love singing like i love
seeing great cosplay even if some of
them are like very suggestive it doesn't
matter because someone put work into
this someone did a [ __ ] photo shoot
and it was [ __ ] great you know and i
feel like that is the difference between
just
like seeing hentai or like really sexy
cosplays on your timeline versus just
seeing you know uh i don't i don't know
what's it like sleaze bait i'm just
gonna call it yeah yeah yeah yeah no i i
get that i get that i mean uh cosplay is
amazing and there's plenty of lewd stuff
out there that uh i enjoy but that's why
i like twitter because you can you can
get like 50 memes and a bunch of loot
stuff all in the same place right
there's variants yeah yeah yeah maybe if
i use tick-tock more and it figured out
that i liked some other stuff
i don't know why i was just kind of like
uh
oh i know and every ad in japan is like
that as well i don't know if it's japan
it might be just japan that's like this
but like every ad i get in japan as well
is like porn or yeah
like dating sites yeah it is literally
like the number one ad that i get on
twitter is this one website where you
can hire girls to speak to you i've seen
that one and i get it yeah all the time
yeah yeah and i'm just like this is sad
that this is like the number one thing
yeah yeah i mean that's a whole nother
thing about loneliness in japan yeah
yeah
guys i i genuinely don't even think like
even after it gets tailored like that
that that will go away because i mean i
feel that's just the main demographic in
japan i mean like how much have you used
tick tock i guess you use tick tock more
i mean i don't when i uh when i say i'm
on tick tock i'm not really like
religiously on tick tock i just go into
it every now and then when i'm like
there's nothing to see on twitter but
again it's like i haven't used it enough
that i see a variance of all sorts of
content i'm still at that early stage
where i see 49 out of 50 girls dancing
yeah same way which is why like i found
myself watching more youtube shorts
because it seems most of them are just
recycled twit tick tocks anyway yeah
yeah but
i i already have a youtube profile and
so a lot of the content is already
tailored to the stuff i've watched on
youtube and every time i log into tiktok
i don't see a lot of these tick tock
trends that have just been become viral
yeah you know even though everyone seems
to be talking about them i'm just like
well it's not appearing on my timeline i
don't know i don't know what i probably
take two shot trends very lightly now
have you seen some of the latest ones
like what like have you seen
like a few more about like date this
episode like i remember a month ago i
just wanted to die inside because there
was this trend called like devious oh
yeah yeah or something which was just
okay
devious licks are just people who just
went to like bathrooms
and kids would start stealing like the
soap dispensers okay and then it started
off as that and then you know how
tick-tock is you know how the internet
is it starts escalating to the point
where people are just full-on like you
know they they're stealing like sinks
sinks
road signs and then there's like people
that stole whole vending machines
okay hold on how the [ __ ] do you steal a
vending machine i totally do that i
don't know you have to pray some of the
logistical abilities here yeah but it's
stealing
but at the same time you're just like
committing like almost grand sex grand
theft auto like and just putting out on
the internet
it was a trend that was widely condemned
and every youtuber under the sun oh yeah
you had a video condemning it i mean
it's easy it's a slam dunk when you're a
youtuber to be like hey guys stealing
bad
applause now please
take my applause you know
i just can't get over that someone had
the balls to steal a vending machine i
don't even think reaper men are allowed
to do that all right man all this all
the treats will still get stuck anyways
yeah yeah that's true i'm just more
surprised that just people were just
stealing and then filming themselves
stealing yeah yeah well people aren't so
smart when clout when cloud has offered
yeah
yeah function like a normal human being
or prison time yeah did you hear about
uh couch guy
or the couch guy no that was very
familiar that was the latest trend as
well i heard about i'm scared to ask um
so it was this girl who basically
surprisingly visited
her boyfriend in college right
and she walks and she walks in and
the guy her boyfriend is sitting on a
couch and he doesn't seem as excited as
you know maybe one would expect okay so
he acts a little bit awkward you know
and uh he then he eventually gets up and
hugs her right and twitter and so i was
going to say twitter tick tock takes
this like 30 second clip and was like
he's cheating on her
he literally like went like full uh
netflix documentary true crime yeah
by frame and like it was insane and it
was just like the worst part of the
internet just like so was he cheating on
her no no no no they said no but they
were like they were like yo they were
like they were like yo calm the [ __ ]
down yeah big big fact
like like maybe he just wasn't excited
no no exactly brother there could there
could be so many ways you you could spin
this narrative right and there were like
literally people
just full-on projecting their narrative
towards this 30-second clip like i saw
this one tiktok that was just like uh
the girl released a statement that was
like that and she said you know this is
there's nothing more to this clip i'm
friends with all the girls you know you
don't need to worry about it i know the
girls yeah and this one woman uh posted
the tick tock being like
girl you don't need to worry
you don't have friends because i've seen
friends like them they are not your
friends
friends should be excited when their
friend steps into the room we've all
been in that position i'm just like if
there's anything i know right if there's
anything worse than an internet
detective it's an internet therapist
like like those are the worst where it's
like let me tell you why your life sucks
you say it's great yeah but it doesn't
let me tell you why it's like dude leave
me alone yeah yeah
yeah it was just like like like you
there is no way you can break down this
much of a narrative through a 30-second
interaction
yeah
i mean there's this it's it's the thing
about the internet right where there's
like some zodiac killer [ __ ] it is it
literally
they found him he died and he left a
review for the movie did he left a
review for the zodiac is it is this
confirmed yeah how did they find him uh
there was i think
he died in like 2017.
quite a while because they found him
there was some scars i can't remember
exactly it doesn't really matter they
found him basically and then he left her
i just i don't care how they found him i
wanted to know what he thought about the
movie yeah and he left a review on the
imdb page
did he say it was good or i think he
didn't like it
i don't know that's just kind of funny
even though it's funny
[Music]
reviews his own movie i don't know why i
just [ __ ] weird
jesus christ anyway before we move on i
forgot to give you something last week
joey uh because me and sid got a bunch
of omiyage for everyone and
i said i said to said i was going to
give this to you on the podcast but uh
here's uh here's some tea i got some tea
i did get joey omiyagi i gave it to you
last week off camera yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not trying to shill my friendship
well no that's perfect because you gave
me cookies yeah
thanks man yeah no worries no because
what i've realized is that we're friends
guys analyze that clip analyze it
analyze that frame by frame well joe joe
he
hesitated
he wasn't as excited as i thought he was
joe jerry wasn't that excited
does that mean there's some [ __ ] going
on there's some [ __ ] going on he's
definitely cheating
you you tell a lie
oh you joke but i mean uh there is some
kind of truth in that in some aspects i
have seen people on reddit or on the
comments right super analyzing our
reactions to things like what i can't
remember there's been there's been a lot
though yeah they'll be like oh wow
connor seems really sad today yeah yeah
but red it's like a [ __ ] free-for-all
when it comes to that kind of stuff
yeah they just say what they want it's
interesting though seeing how our people
perceive us sometimes yeah and sometimes
in a good way sometimes in a bad way
yeah because that doesn't everyone
always say that you always look angry or
like tired yeah everyone's like oh kind
of i am tired a lot of the time yeah
that's because i have to i wake up early
but um i you know yeah some people like
he's angry i'm like no i'm just that's
just how i am that's just his resting
face you'll know if i'm angry um
well you maybe you're there i don't know
i'll storm off yeah he just won't be
here
yeah
yeah no but like yeah reddit i've seen
some stuff on reddit where it's like wow
you got it ain't that deep bro like you
didn't have to go that deep you know
it's it's it's difficult because on one
aspect i understand that
all they have to go off of
ours is our episodes
and that's all they have to go off yes
yeah but i wouldn't by any stretch of
the imagination say that trash taste is
reflective of
well i guess it is reflective of who i
am but you miss a lot of nuance right
like it's very easy to generalize
um who we are and it also is a show
right so we are we do you know that i
won't lie there's times where i'm like
i'm going to keep this argument going
because it's great content yeah
a lot of the times i wouldn't some of
the arguments i get into with conor or
joey are not arguments i'd get into with
a random stranger right because because
i i i would just i don't even though i
do feel strongly about a lot of things
as you guys know very well
i also in general life just don't give a
[ __ ]
to argue yeah i i like arguing in this
space with the boys
sometimes i do like to be able to
explore other sides of opinions yeah
yeah
but it also is like if it is a you know
sometimes there are controversial
opinions yeah but they are opinions and
then they are sometimes commonly held
opinions
and it's one of those things where i
would like to play devil's advocate in
some situations uh without having to be
like conor is that kind of person he's
yeah just to get the conversation right
yeah you know we've always said we don't
have to be a circle jerk no no and i
always want to be able to talk about
topics
and say things yeah it just makes more
for a more interesting show yeah yeah
and you know if anything i i would wish
that sometimes we would like not assume
exactly
our thoughts and opinions on things
based off certain things this episode is
sponsored by harry's guys are you
heading back to the office anytime soon
i'm in the office right now
it's time to get back fresh clean and
all shaven looking business-like and let
harry's help you guys if you don't know
harry's it's time you do because harry's
was created to be hitting different from
other shaving companies
you see that little little reference
harry's crossed high quality long
lasting blades and durable weighted
handles that make a close comfortable
shave quick and dare we say
enjoyable
and because harry's insist that you
shouldn't have to choose between a great
shave and a fair price they just give
you both refilling blades starts as low
as two bucks even easier new harry's
customers get their starter set which
includes a five blade razor weighted
handle foaming gel with aloe and a
travel cover it's a thirteen dollar
value all for just three dollar three
are you wow three is that a typo
damn that is insane value and they have
a bunch of other products and now i've
actually used harry's a bunch myself
when i uh went to the uk uh when i was
getting on the plane i actually saw
harry's in the store and oh yeah i
wanted to buy more but there's none in
japan and i actually bought a bunch uh
so
you're literally stocked up on harry's
so there's never been a better time to
try harry's go to harris.com trash to
get their starter set for just three
bucks it's 100 satisfaction guarantee so
you've got nothing to lose go to
harris.com trash right now to get its
special offer that's h-a-r-r-y-s
slash trash links down in the
description below back to the episode
like one thing that i hate about the
internet right and this is one thing
that i absolutely despise about being an
online creator is that
so if i want to talk bad about something
i always have to preface it before right
and we did this early with the uh thing
with um like me saying like i don't want
to see
uh you know girls dancing
uh that is trying to entice you know
yeah
i have to then preface that by saying i
support sex work yeah yeah yeah i i
think it should just should be a given
that that's right right so that's the
way i feel but it sucks on the internet
that i have to always preface that okay
i support this this this yeah but and i
hate that fact that i i can't just talk
i have to then be like go through the
checklist okay i want to talk about uh
uh this stuff all right cool i've got to
make sure everyone knows that i support
this this this this and it's like no no
you've got to read out the fine printing
because because because
someone is always going to assume the
worst of you they're always going to
assume that what you're saying
is the worst thing and there's kind of a
bad place that they don't agree you
can't you can't say anything bad about
something that they agree with
because they don't want to hear it yeah
yeah and you know it's and it's over the
internet especially if it was
impersonally probably a different thing
because that's the biggest thing i've
noticed about speaking online on the
internet and speaking to someone person
to person you like
online you do have to preface a lot of
things because it seems like in person
to person people are more willing to
give you the benefit of the doubt
hundred percent
yeah and online people aren't willing to
give you the benefit of the doubt a lot
of the times i think the other problem
as well is that on the internet it's
very much a one-way conversation yeah
yeah yeah so you have to give your
entire spiel all in one go yeah
otherwise you know if they do reply back
to you then it's not going to be this
conversation yeah it's just going to be
like shooting the messenger kind of deal
right it's like it sucks that on the
internet you know common sense isn't as
common as people make it out like like
you know when we when we say bad things
about japan right that comes from a
place of
loving japan and being here for a while
we're we're here for a reason right we
like we love this place yeah and we love
living here but it sucks that every time
this has only happened to japan in the
uk i never have to say i love the uk
yeah no only with japan do you have to
say i love japan
yeah like because it has this weird
stigma but there's a lot of topics that
you have to do that on the internet you
if you want to say anything bad about it
you have to be like i love this thing
but yeah and if you don't say that
before people are like and they say
you're against you come from a place of
hating yeah you know yeah and it's it's
so frustrating that that's what it's
become because i feel that there are so
many discussions that are so [ __ ]
bloated because you have to [ __ ] go
through the checklist
of all this [ __ ] nonsense that is the
biggest difference between us talking in
a pub
like and us talking on trash taste which
we have the same kind of conversation
but it's like you put you put yourself
through a buffer
or a safety net right like of the of the
things you're about to say whereas i
wouldn't need to do that if like there
were no cameras filming it's like like
putting on the seat belts
like there's 50. like the whole like way
way back with the gambling episode right
yeah like i never ever once thought for
a second and we were doing that episode
right this is this is probably like a
quite a well-known episode amongst the
viewers yeah that that you guys were
addicted to gambling right i know you
guys you guys are not addicted to
gambling
at no point in your life when i say you
i
you we never had a vanity show right and
uh you know and it was weird how
because we didn't preface that because
we didn't say because you even though
you guys were playing devil's advocate
to me and i was very much i was very
much arguing in gantry specifically yeah
that there should be more regulation and
that it should be like that and you guys
are just playing devil's advocate with
me right yeah yeah i know that you guys
aren't addicted to gotcha yeah but it
was weird seeing a lot of the comments
just jump to conclusions and being like
they must be addicted to gacha because
they don't agree with connor's opinion
yeah and it's like all right you can you
can
you can be you can not gamble and not be
a gambler but also think that gantry
doesn't need any more that's the problem
is that if you don't specify then they
think that you're on the very end of the
spectrum yeah yeah yeah it was just like
it's like you're not allowed to be in
the middle yeah it was just weird seeing
all the comments getting so aggressive
about it yeah like people got like angry
about it and it's happened on a few
other episodes as well yeah i mean i i
think like it kind of happened quite
recently with you isn't it yeah like
debates oh my god which like i i think i
think we i think the problem with that
was that we were arguing like two
different things yeah yeah and so it was
that was a weird one that was yeah yeah
and uh people people took me i was
because i was trying to argue that you
know you can have drip no matter how
much you pay for it or how much is how
much the clothes are worth and you were
arguing that you know don't support fast
fashion and you know
try to
you know you try to buy things or buy
clothes that are more sustainable yeah
the environment yeah and you care more
about quality nowadays and people took
that as wow connor and joey have just
like lost their way
people like wow khan is so goddamn
privileged and by most matrix i am
privileged
i'm never pretending to be like i'm i
live it like like i come from like
uh
yeah i've never pretended yeah and
everyone's like you know it was really
[ __ ] weird that was because at no
point in that argument did i ever argue
that that
drip had to be expensive clothes i my
main argument was that the word drip
initially came from you know high-end
when you were like the rappers who would
wet grip and it was all branded it had
to be branded you know that was my
argument and at no point did i ever
argue that cheap clothes didn't look
good yeah but for some reason the
comment section took me arguing that i
prefer quality clothes not not looks
quality like i prefer stuff that lasts
longer yeah and i don't support fast
fashion and all that they're like oh
well you know you're all these fast
fashion all the high-end ones are using
slave labor anyway it's like well then
you're just generalizing it you're
putting them all in the bubble exactly
but i never made that argument right it
was it was really bizarre you didn't you
didn't
i i guess the the issue was that you
didn't put that safety net right
i never and at no point did i say drip
has to equal money yeah and that was the
problem because because i didn't say
that people assumed
that i was thinking that people love to
assume and what's even funnier is at one
point
joey you so i watched it right joey
joked saying yeah grip is expensive you
were joking though yeah yeah but joey it
was mainly me people were out
i was like what is happening and it was
like the whole comment was like conor's
privilege is really showing man he's
he's i'm like what and they're like men
they they think with a first world
mindset and i was thinking that like i
was like
not from a first world country of course
i'm gonna think i'm trying my best to
learn and to to expand uh my horizons
and learn more about other countries but
you know i'm obviously gonna think
through a first world perspective like
that's because that's my world right i
don't like is it is it wrong of me to to
have that perspective i'm curious no
because i feel that's the only
perspective but like i'm trying to learn
about other things right
i mean i mean but in the case with that
argument it's very difficult to bring in
a different perspective right like that
right without making no sense yeah i
mean i think the i think the uh argument
is that you know yes do you support
sustainable yeah
fashion um
but a lot of people from third world
countries can't you know yeah
being able to substitute being able to
support sustainable fashion is in itself
a privilege because right right a lot of
people can't do that right
and you know some people do
at the moment have no choice but to buy
cheap fashion because they can hardly
afford anything else that's completely
okay never hold it against anyone you
know when i was buying those i mentioned
like when i was buying the suit there
was like 30 pounds right yeah that was
because that was all i could afford yeah
right i didn't i didn't get there was no
other option i couldn't i couldn't even
like entertain the idea of getting a
suit that cost a hundred right but
obviously when you're when you're doing
better and you have more income i i do
think it's more of a responsible thing
to do to try and buy things more
ethically that's the thing right like in
that episode you never once said right
yeah yeah [ __ ] your income
expensive clothes
i remember seeing this other argument of
like well you know they just overpriced
the clothes etc etc and
yeah sometimes they do yeah they do but
also you know it's i've had this debate
coming from uh you know doing voice
acting a lot
which is a job that takes one hour most
of the time yeah and you get you can get
paid like ten thousand dollars yeah most
people would think that's would argue
that's absurd you should never get paid
that much for one hour of work but it's
the it's what goes into being able to do
it in one hour yeah the reason why i
could do that in one hour is because i'm
trained and i can do the job
professionally i know how to use the
equipment i know how to do everything in
a way where you couldn't just take
someone you get the quality of sound
right you get you get somebody who can
do the quality that you want within one
hour in a professional way and it's the
same way with clothes to me like if i
want to suit right absolutely if i am if
i am in a good enough position to be
able to afford a suit that is a nice
suit and i can get it made for me
specifically right and get it because
you know i gotta i have the problem that
i have short legs massive ass so pants
don't scale
like that they scale wide and down right
so normally i i the pants i have to get
like fitted yeah because my eyes are
super [ __ ] just too tough
dummy thick
so so like that was always a [ __ ]
challenge right i always had jeans that
were either too short or too tight yeah
right and i still have that problem
because yeah you can't get taylor fit
jeans
they probably can without paying
attention
i don't know what they are but sure it's
really easy to get fitted yeah yeah so i
i think as well like so if you were to
get like let's say you go to a tailor
right you're paying a tailor who knows
how to do it well he's done this for
like 20 years he's experienced his whole
life he can promise you that he'll do a
good deal it's worth the extra money if
you have the money and you know you can
support a local business if it is one
right i think if you again this is only
if you have the luxury like it's it's
certainly a privilege to be able to do
that and i would never ever get in
anyone's case for not doing that well i
mean i mean i mean if you've got to you
got to do what you've got to do to
survive right [ __ ] everyone else but
that's the thing it's like what i don't
understand is the criticism towards like
how you spend your own hard-earned money
it's like yeah yeah yeah it's like i
earned that money myself i'll do with
that money however i please it's like
leave me alone that's a good point as
well like i was like you know you're not
taking care of my finances like why are
you kidding listen the only the only
questionable decision i make is my jojo
collection right that's the i'll give
you props for that
but everything
compare us to other youtubers i think
we're pretty [ __ ] normal yeah i think
so too where is our lambos
yeah when i rent a car you know you know
what car i rent a toyota yaris
i love the toyota great car
it is a great coach on that car is
fantastic it's perfect size it's not too
big we don't even own cars
i hate this thing where people are like
they they judge us for what like we're
[ __ ] doing with our lives and it's
like bro just like i don't come to your
house and be like really hot pockets
cringe bro yeah you got cheese puffs
yeah like no like what like what is this
i
i don't know yeah because because like
you're going back to what you were
saying about getting paid for like doing
an hour of voice acting getting paid
like a certain amount that voice actors
do get paid and i i give this example to
like every artist right or every anyone
working in that kind of field which is
you go to you then you have to ask the
client then okay so would you rather pay
the same amount for me to do this work
in
five hours or in 10 hours to get the
same amount of work um and if they say
yeah or no then
then you then you can say that okay so
i'm being punished for doing my job well
efficiently right in this time period so
you'd rather pay someone else to do the
same work
for more time even though
even though you're paying them for like
you're paying for the same amount of
work but you're paying them to do it
less efficiently than you yeah but like
the perception is that because you're
doing it this well you're giving them
the same amount of work for a shorter
period of time that you're charging that
much and that's that's just how the
industry is you know you're not you're
not just paying for hours worked in
you're paying for skill as well and
skill is part of the pricing that you
pay absolutely and also you know when
it's these big advertising companies in
what realm is it fair for your voice to
be plastered over say mcdonald's all
over the country yeah yeah it's a
branding issue as well yeah yeah like
it's it's it's they're using your voice
so you you have a certain right to to
sell that what is the earth right
exactly there's a lot of jobs like that
like you know like the art design
graphic design modeling yeah anything
you know it's if it's if it's a
although like stuff like voice acting i
100 admit like it seems very easy from
the outside but to be able to do it
consistently and perform
what the person wants and be able to
adjust and be able to do it all
professionally it's very difficult to be
able to do it over and over again
build a reputation still got a long way
to go man there's people who are much
better than me yeah yeah who can do it
but you know at the end of the day you
want to make sure everyone's getting the
right right yeah and it's yeah it's it's
uh it's one of those tough decisions
money is always one of those topics that
is so polarizing depending on uh what's
going on yeah and uh where you're from
and your just your opinions on it like
you know um
i've had people uh close to me who
have been like very critical of me
earning money doing what i do yeah and
they they've been like well i do i do x
thing like uh i i do ex thing that's
more um contributing to society so i
don't think it's right that you would
get paid more than me and that whole
argument i absolutely despise as well
yeah because it's like what can you say
to that that will get them to understand
right yeah it's like if you're if you're
uh if you work in like medicine or
something and you firmly believe that
that you are doing something more
important i would argue you are doing
exactly more importantly you are but but
that's just
that's just business that's how it is
this is how it works we don't make up
the rules i i think there are jobs that
are far more important than the jobs
that we have now absolutely the the fact
that teachers get paid what they do i
think is
[ __ ] tragic [ __ ] atrocious yeah
absolutely and i think they should like
get much better pay yeah and but it's
also like you got to do what you got to
do make your own bag you know what i
mean like i'm
the world doesn't do any favors yeah
that's not something we can do anything
yeah man i i i will advocate for for
change and i i will do what i can from
my position uh but also bro this
economy's right
you know
you know you know you know it's bad when
it's like yo what the [ __ ] that youtuber
can afford a house yeah
this guy just makes videos what world
are we in where like now
being wealthy is you can afford a house
yeah exactly like i'm i'm trying to
secure my future because i don't know
how long this job likes exactly
i'm trying to do well while i can you
know and i i would never criticize
anyone who is trying to do what they
need to do uh to succeed in life
if you're not [ __ ] over somebody do
what you need to do yeah you know like
as long as you're not active hurting or
ruining someone's life you do what you
got to do to get by and um you do what
you need to do man i i firmly believe
that
whatever you want to do don't hurt
anyone go go for it no because i i think
one thing that
one aspect of our job which
uh which we wouldn't have as like a
normal office worker for example is job
security like if you want to get in this
field and you want job security i think
we have negative job security
like you know how hard it is to like uh
you know you apply for like credit cards
or yeah anything long-term financing
yeah i want to know your annual income
yeah yeah it is literally impossible to
give a number as a youtuber yeah it's
like it's like the most roughest the
mystery because it's like all right so
i'm not gonna be honest with you it
could be like 1k or it could be 20k or
100k so basically the whole spectrum of
money it could be anywhere
it's hard to go to a banker and go well
i i think the next video might do really
well
just just like i'm pretty certain so
like i'm thinking maybe like this
there must be like the banks when they
first you know met youtubers they
thought they were like horse gambling or
something like that
i got a lucky fool about number seven
next week man i'm telling you man
they were definitely like money money
laundering yeah
this is this is the this is like this is
what we think like nfts are now right
they were just like you you're you earn
how much is a youtuber no no no i ain't
touching somebody money just comes in
yeah you don't buy it or sell anything
what do you say
who pays you yeah i remember i remember
the first time like having to answer
that question like when applying for
like our visas and stuff like that and
i'm having to explain who pays us i'm
just like well
google
so and so like you said and so
[Music]
yeah
yeah and then we have this thing called
patreon where people pay us to uh play
so exist
it's like every like red flag is being
ticked yeah yeah yeah like yeah like
like when you're a doctor right you your
job is secure like oh yeah yeah unless
you go around killing people you're
pretty good like you you know it would
be rough not to be employed
i just realized how on paper like how
similar we must look to like a drug
dealer
laundering money if you go to the
checklist so you can you just get money
put into your account
when i have to talk to your accountants
man it is it is the most stressful thing
because they're just like i can see on
the zoom calls the look on their face
while i'm telling them what i'm doing
yeah just like
okay i thought i find a hilarious just
the situation of a drug dealer going to
bank to get a loan it's like
it's like so do you so you sell drugs do
you work for the farm
no
i haven't got the drugs yet so this is
kind of like a like you know collateral
yeah
drug dealers what do you do i'm a
youtuber
i provide a service
i guess it's a timely topic well not
timely it's still like three weeks late
but the whole twitch thing as well right
the earnings oh yeah yeah people finding
out how much creators make what was your
number joey i don't even know
i was like probably twenty thousand or
something i don't stream so well no no
you you you are you're in top ten
thousand ducks
we're both league hell yeah yeah let's
go feels bad
this is this is why i'm i'm a man of the
people i am the ma i am the man of the
people
i recommend i i represent the common
folks
he's doing god's work right here
i hope i hope our youtube earnings get
leaked before the next year
so that this age is poorly forgotten
oh my god that was that was funny it was
seeing it was funny seeing the reaction
because you know as somebody who's been
doing this yeah i'm i was not surprised
of seeing these numbers no absolutely
not um and also i try to tell i always
try and explain to people you know the
reason why let's say xqc is earning
seven million and getting all this
absurd amounts of money what it seems
like absurd is that
you know that if if that's the the
number one person in music is making
billions of person tv is making millions
right number one at anything is making
[ __ ] tons of money yeah yeah if you're
in the top 100 of something in the world
you're probably making a lot of money i
mean if someone was bothered to leak it
you'd wouldn't you have a suspicion that
it might be a lot of money yeah yeah and
also also
there's no point leaking something where
the number one sport is making like 15
if
for for this to exist right for the
system to exist where let's say that
creator you watch who is making a
hundred viewers yeah which is all of us
at one time yeah right we were all that
one channel i i distinctly remember for
for a year or two where i only got like
40 to 100 views on twitch which i was
very happy with yeah absolutely
for that person to go to make income and
and somewhat support themselves
there has to be a person at the top
who's proportionally making a lot more
depending on the audience size right of
course yeah it's a system that works
is it super fair that some people make
[ __ ] hundreds of millions uh
it's up to you you know i mean all i
will say is that those from what i saw
there is a lot more money on youtube as
opposed to twitch
from what it seems so the amount of work
you do as well especially yeah i mean
the the the youtube uh like the top 100
youtubers are probably making a lot more
than the top 100 twitch streams yeah i
understand yeah yeah i don't know how it
works i think so as well um i mean you
sound like mr beast there's no mr beast
on twitch
and all the ones that are on twitch that
involve money and gambling are extremely
sketchy yeah very very sketchy
definitely and uh that's a whole other
thing the whole gambling side of twitch
is [ __ ] yeah that's a whole lot like
that
he likes i mean youtube inherently is a
massive platform much bigger than
twitter it is much bigger than twitter
so you know yeah like
some of these channels that are
uploading you know like god knows how
much darman's making yeah i'm sure he
makes xqc's uh revenue in one day yeah
he's from eastern sponsors right like
it's it's totally crazy and we
i i am still shocked that people are
like
top influencers earn how much you know
when there are some of them that are
going around in
private jets lamborghinis and all this
stuff right it's you know i wish i was i
wish that was me it out i mean i mean i
would i'd love to buy my whole the all
of wales you know some of these guys
have the gdp of wales i'd love to to
reinvigorate the economy yeah yeah i
mean are we surprised how much hollywood
movie actors make or how much some of
the top music is
yeah and then like and then
like this is like a new entertainment
platform of course top creators are
going to be making millions you know
we're not at the billion stage yet
because we're not as big as the other
entertainment industries but these are
what the top creators are making and
that's just
we are just like a baby mode of the
entertainment industry you know of like
the rest of the uh establishing saving
industry
i'm sure when like massive hollywood
actors were first you know starting to
make these like massive loads of money
and that got found out i'm sure the
general public was like wait these
actors make how much money like it's
exactly i feel it's the exact same thing
it's like it's such a new thing now and
it's also just so unprecedented because
it's so different to anything that you
see on like tv or radio or anything like
that because it's just three guys trying
to justify their income the conversation
yeah pretty much and like the twitch
thing it's like it's most of it's public
anyway yeah that was that was it was
especially weird yeah such thing is that
most content creators sub count is
public and this income was somewhat
known or close to node right you could
easily have like kind of guest yeah yeah
right so it's like quite odd why is it a
surprise it's quite weird but i i i
think the people that i think a lot of
content creators were like a common
people who are still surprised about it
um i think the people that were
surprised about it were people who
weren't involved
yeah watched twitch or weren't
you know touching it at all yeah yeah
and i saw we were being like i'm going
to be a twitch stream like yeah right
good luck
that [ __ ] is harder than youtube
yeah
twitch is [ __ ] hard right yeah yeah
uh and it's it's the search algorithms
aren't nearly as optimized as youtube or
tick tock or something um yeah well i
mean it's it just shows that you know
there is this is a growing industry
right now like this is it's it's weird
seeing how youtube and twitch have
evolved as time has gone on yeah and
seeing it go i think that's where the
different lies and where they get their
perspective from which was the
difference between say twitch streamers
and youtubers versus hollywood
celebrities or big music artists is that
you know we a lot of us
started off in that exact same position
as everyone else you know it is an equal
playing field so we don't get we didn't
have to go through these auditions
or you know go get signed by this
massive music label or anything like
that we grew organically buyers by
ourselves and i think i think it's just
the shock that someone who
went through that avenue is able to earn
that much right but it's but it's also
like
you know i i think
what a lot of people don't like to give
credit to is that a lot of the creators
who
are earning that much now right at some
point or another they were they were
working full-time hours on top of
whatever else they were doing yeah on
something that wasn't paying them yeah
but that's the thing it's like years
yeah i feel like twitch streamers again
is like a lot like youtube is where like
the biggest difference is that i think a
lot of people see them more as like this
person that's on the same level right
it's like a lot more personable it's
just like the dude across the road right
now whereas like you know no one views
[ __ ] yeah johnny depp is like the guy
right right kanye west could like burn a
billion dollars and people would be like
oh kanye yeah that's just kanye being
kanye but if a youtuber did that it
would be like oh my god
it's different right and there is this
weird kind of dichotomy of how they with
i
expect the standards of traditional
celebrities to to influences and stuff
and uh
i forgot what's going to say i was going
to something else god you probably could
tell i'm [ __ ] dumb
i was going to say something after
joey's point i totally forgot it what
was joey's point again uh my point was
that twitch stream is on youtube as a
scene a lot more is like just like a
friend yeah like you know a lot more
personal not this person
in the clouds like a lot of like
hollywood actors do you ever
give it because
you know when you when you first start
making money on youtube it's exciting
yeah right you doing he's like oh my god
i made a hundred bucks yeah it's crazy
it's insane and then you're really proud
because you're like oh my god i can get
paid for doing this thing that i love
yeah yeah you know and then for the
first two years i was making enough to
maybe buy myself a movie ticket yeah
ten
the first year i think i only made like
500 dollars from it
second year probably made like five
thousand dollars still not enough to
live off but you know i was like wow
exciting and then it goes up and it
scales up and that's when i think you
start to feel bad about how much money
you're making yeah right yeah do you
ever get like imposter syndrome about it
yeah of course i think every year i
think most
nearly every youtuber yeah get imposter
syndrome the reason why a lot of
youtubers don't want to talk about that
money is because a lot of them feel bad
i think yeah
which they i don't think they should
right i wish we lived in a system where
no one gave a [ __ ] about money and
people could be more honest about it and
that people could because then i think
that would make sense that's why i'm
glad this twitch thing came out because
now yeah people are like wearing their
[ __ ] earnings with on their badges
yeah well because i think that it makes
a better atmosphere for everyone to be
able to negotiate for better like pay in
their job
you know there's a like in traditional
jobs there's sometimes even though
they're not allowed to ask you to do
this the bosses will be like don't talk
about how much money you're making yeah
but you're allowed to but people don't
because they're scared and they don't
want to they don't want to be judged but
if you're doing the exact same thing as
your colleague whether it be on twitch
or in the same job you should be able to
argue that you should be valued the same
way they are yeah and it's one of those
things where when i meet other content
creators um in private i'll ask them
like how much did you get for this
sponsorship deal yeah and i'll be like
what did you get cuz i want to make sure
you didn't get [ __ ] over yeah because
i know how much you should be getting
because because like speaking from
people
people in the industry no one nobody
teaches each other and one of the
stupidest things that a lot of content
creators don't talk to each other about
this even though the more content
creators you talk to the more you
realize oh a lot of people are getting
[ __ ] because they've never talked to
any other content creator about this
yeah like taking deals that like for
example like i took a deal for a sponsor
on a video this is when i was getting
around about an average fifty thousand
to a hundred thousand views i took a
sponsorship for a hundred dollars
what and the video got half a million
views that's not that's not worth it by
the way something a video let's say when
you're about if you have 50 thousand to
a hundred thousand average views you
should probably be getting about about
maybe two thousand to four thousand
dollars yeah at least twenty to fifty
times yeah two thousand four thousand
years which sounds like a lot i know i
know that sounds like a lot to a lot of
people um but this is advertising space
right this is eyeballs that you're
getting so you have to think of it like
that um so you can you can naturally i
mean i guess that's where our knowledge
comes in right where right it's it's
it's not like that's not a set number
because it all it all depends on the
client it all depends on the product
you're promoting some clients in certain
spaces are willing to
uh are willing to sell you like this
spot for a higher price some aren't yeah
it's yeah it really comes down to
experience but
if you're a content creator you should
really be talking to other content
creators if you have no idea what to
charge a client right if you have no
idea
then i've i've like because here's the
thing i've searched up
i've searched up uh like before like
youtube of like how much you should be
charging
certain clients and and like
all the youtubers i've seen who have
said how much you you should be charging
have got the have got the number wrong
you know and that's because a lot of
them aren't
aren't big creators
and like the numbers the numbers really
depend on where you are on youtube and
it really comes down to experience and
what your other p what other people are
doing in your fields which really
depends on how much you can charge right
so i i feel like i feel like talking to
you guys about it
before we we are now able to charge more
because we've realized that we all get
to charge different prices yeah for
certain it's it's also not just about
like the the sub count and like view
count stuff like that so i feel a lot of
it especially nowadays that like
companies are looking for is like
branding power yeah but you could have
the like two channels could have the
exact same number of subs and views but
yeah one could be a stronger brand and
that depends on the in and of itself
right yeah and it depends on like the
audience and the demographic so there's
so many components that go into it it's
not just like a bare bones like i get
this many views on average therefore i
should be getting this amount of money
like yeah it's completely case-by-case
which which is like my general advice to
anyone who is independent and not even a
youtuber but an artist right we've had
to learn
what our value is that's that's the
biggest thing you have you have to like
you have to know what your value is and
not be ashamed and not be ashamed to say
whether they ask how much it costs
like when it comes to negotiations with
a company or with a fellow client you
can't be ashamed to big up your value
because
you are bringing something for them
right you are you are bringing something
to the table and you need to articulate
that nothing hurts me more than seeing
an artist underselling themselves oh man
it hurts so much so it's so it hurts me
so much i i always make sure like if i'm
working with an artist i'm like
you sure you want that much like i can
give you more i think you're worth a
little bit more than that you gotta you
have a little bit of confidence in
yourself yeah like exactly
obviously you can't like ask for an
egregious amount at a small price but
you know there is a limit that you can
go and it's okay to step over that limit
even slightly just to get your name out
there you know if you really believe in
your work
um but yeah just oh my god i've seen so
many [ __ ] artists just be like yeah
i'll give you like this amount and it's
like a tenth of what i was envisioning
it's like uh yeah i don't know if you
want to do that too yeah like
be a little more confident in yourself
you know this episode is sponsored by
honey we all shop online and we've all
seen that promo code field taunt us at
the checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past money is the free
browser extension that scours internet
promoter codes and applies the best when
it finds your card honey supports over
30 000 online stores they range from
sites from tech gaming products to
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery all right picture this in your
head ladies and gentlemen i'm gonna i'm
gonna paint a mental image for you right
now all right imagine you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites i see okay
when you're at the checkout the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click apply coupons oh my god all
right you wait a few seconds and honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll just watch the prices look
at the price you're dropping oh my god
oh joey joey
i can only get sorry wrecks joey i have
a question how much money did you see
well as you know i've been moving
recently and i've just saved twenty
dollars on new kitchen equipment for my
new house honey has found it's over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings and if you don't already have
honey you can be straight up missing out
on free savings it's literally free and
in stores in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast so get
honey for free at jordanhoney.com
taste that's join honey.com trash taste
back to the episode and i think another
thing that peop a lot of people don't
talk about when it comes to like the
economics of youtube and like getting
getting paid for this as a job is that
is the amount of time
a lot of content creators will go before
they get big doing work and not getting
paid and not doing this for money i mean
i i did youtube for like seven eight
years before i saw my first paycheck
right um and especially in especially
nowadays it's a super super competitive
industry in a super super competitive
field so my like whenever someone comes
to me and asks me for advice about how
to make youtube a job i i the first
thing i ask them is do you have the time
to take a year off a year off in your
life without getting paid and working at
night like working harder than a
nine-to-five job yeah because that's
like that's the minimum sacrifice you
will have to do nowadays to unless
you're like super super lucky to do
youtube and even if you do that you
might not even get popular you might
you know it might not even come to
fruition so are you willing to take to
make that sacrifice in your life for a
chance to have this as a job which is
why like i feel very lucky to have this
position yeah but you know i i did i i
do you know i i do know that i there was
some portion of luck within my career
path but also
everyone i've met including all three of
us worked super [ __ ] hard as well we
went through a point where we were
working harder than a nine-to-five job
without getting paid or being paid like
less than minimum wage to get where we
are we did that for about a year and i
feel like i feel like a lot of people
who are maybe older
who are more established to be like you
know i got a nine-to-five job i can't
really take a year out in my life that's
why a lot of youtubers you see start off
in like college or in high school when
you do have that time and
all i can say to that is i'm you know
i'm sorry that's just the way it works
you can't you can't like it's it's it's
not a company youtube youtube isn't like
youtube you're not a paid salary man you
know it's yeah i mean like as an example
it's like you know like mr beast like
jimmy was
barely got any views for like the first
like six seven years of his career and
then all of a sudden he's he's that
where he's at now right but like i think
what a lot of people forget is that he
didn't just come out of nowhere he
didn't just make a video and it
immediately you know get him 50 million
subs right it's like it takes a long
time he worked for that [ __ ] it takes a
very long time yeah and that's the thing
that everyone wants to gloss over yeah
and that's not me just trying to justify
why people should make 50 [ __ ]
million dollars a year but yeah it's
just
you should you can't criticize it
without first understanding that and
appreciating that it does sometimes take
a [ __ ] ton of work yeah you know and uh
the one thing uh that people love to
forget is that life is not fair
you know it's like it's not it's not
it's not a fair system right now could
um you know you could put
just as many hours if not more hours
into playing guitar or something and
nothing could come of it yeah i always
think of the the hundreds and thousands
of guitarists
right it's like you also have to unders
like i think
one thing that is kind of
oversold in life is that if you put x of
hours into something it will just work
out yeah and it's not
not always that simple you know if
you're getting into something that is
extremely popular worldwide yeah it's
going to be way harder than if you're
for example making anime videos on a
website called youtube in 2015. yeah
i
i mean it's differences in scale of what
you're trying to compete you know i'm
sure everyone on will everyone in the
world started doing the type content
that we were doing i think we'd be out
of a job pretty soon because no doubt
there'd be other people who are better
than us yeah that would happen but
that's not but not everyone is doing it
yeah that's necessary i mean i feel
that's why it's called a dream job for a
reason right yeah i mean i mean like i i
did take a [ __ ] massive risk with my
career choices you know because back
then i i went i had a steady pay job i
had a career path i could pursue and i
like did you work out again i i worked
at the bbc did you know that did you
know that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
had to bring it back i had to bring it
back from the bingo
in the [ __ ] timestamps it'll be like
justifying our privilege
this section of the [ __ ] yeah
no because yeah i i did i did sacrifice
that a proven career path for an
industry that was not proven that an
industry that didn't exist back then
that i i that wasn't proven well that i
could do this more than a year or two
and i took a risk that it was going to
turn out to something and i was lucky
enough that it did turn out you know
um nowadays it's a different ball game
you know i i i took that risk with my
career path if you want to be a youtuber
or a twitch streamer you have to take a
different risk and it's it's a different
risk but
the risk to rewards is like the rewards
are there to be seen and that's why
people take risks to get that reward
the one lucky thing about youtube and
twitch is that you can do it in your
downtime you know you can put a little
bit of effort here and there yeah see
some results see that there's a demand
for it and then dedicate more time to it
that is one good thing about it like you
know yes you're you're going to be at
disadvantage if you are working like god
said and you are 30 plus and you've got
a life that you need to maintain yeah
but it's not impossible like there is
there are some ways it's not impossible
and there are cases where it has worked
out again yeah it's just harder and the
playing field isn't level but it never
is yeah no you know uh i'm sure that if
you uh let's say you just had a friend
who is a big youtuber you're already at
a massive advantage because they can
help you out oh yeah or you have a
family history of using cameras or
editing you know like there's all kinds
of variations of advantages but that's
[ __ ] life yeah i feel like i could
apply with any job literally anything in
life you know but i guess because we're
somewhat public figures so it's a lot
more i mean i mean i would say every
career path has their own obstacles
especially especially like for example
if i would take engineering for example
it's actually
not advantageous to you to do like to do
a good job in your company and stay in
that company because like the raises you
get are better if you move companies and
you're constantly moving companies right
and that you know i don't think that
should be right because i think you
should be i think every employee should
be rewarded for doing a good job at that
company yeah but the sad reality of it
of it is is that a lot of the times in a
lot of career paths you can get a much
better raise by changing companies and
then moving back to the original company
and you're thinking like why can't i
just why can't the original company just
see me for my worth to begin with it's
like twitch stream is moving to youtube
back to twitch
[Music]
free privileged individuals justify them
you know the one thing that
the one comment that i absolutely i know
i'm just i'm inviting this comment okay
you've changed
i like the old blank better and it's
like
are you saying that i should i would be
the same person i am at 20 years old
that i am now because you're insane
however if you think that i should be
the same person of course i'm going to
change yeah if i didn't do youtube i
would still change it would change
regardless i'm becoming more miserable
jane
you change right and yeah when people
comment saying like oh they've changed
you know they're different from like yes
of course as you should you should
become more confident as you get i would
be worried i would be worried if you
didn't change right you should you
should mature you should change your
opinion you should act differently
that's that's called life if you're not
doing that what are you doing yeah what
are you why why aren't you changing why
aren't you improving yourself yeah
exactly you know but then i guess that's
up but then yeah that's the thing it's
like
instead of going to primark how dicky
it all changed when conor got this
pumpkin spice latte he had starbucks for
the first time you have chased it all
changed
[Laughter]
that one trip to los angeles has changed
seriously i changed my mind
i'm not gonna be broke anymore
no but i mean i agree you should or you
should always be changing you know i i
think there is a difference between
changing and uh you know becoming a bit
snobby
yeah because you know for like i still
can't stand
well what can i say i still can't stand
um flex culture oh my god yeah well it's
weird isn't it because you want to be
able to celebrate and support the people
who have really worked hard and have
done great stuff and have made some good
content and you you know you i want to
see them like do well yeah but then i
guess there's a very fine line
especially for audiences yeah one is
considered flexing and what is yeah i'm
not i'm not going to go around be like
oh this is what i bought i'm doing i'm
killing it you know
all my investments are doing well
i
so there's no flexing from me
unfortunately
um
but it is a fine line between like what
is flexing and what is just being proud
of your accomplishments right yeah
it's it's like what what is that where
how when does it change [ __ ] it's hard
isn't it because you don't want to be
like yeah i'm doing well but you also
you know because that some people
perceive that as
you've changed yeah yeah right so what
do you do not want me to like show you
my achievements or
because people people support small
creators and then they also
turn on them when they're when they find
out they're doing well sometimes which
is yeah it's the underground band going
yeah it is yeah just just just in a
different field you know they've changed
everything ever since they were
successful and signed by the music label
you know don't like their music anymore
they're talking about different things
i like them before they became an
animator
you know i i i don't get annoyed if
someone prefers all the content of mine
or they prefer because the style has
changed yeah right and i understand that
when you change your style not every
style is for everyone exactly and i
don't get annoyed and people like i
prefer the old videos i'm like that's
fair enough right like i get it like
it's your taste all right yeah but i'm
not going to change it because that's
not what i want to do yeah i mean i i
still get comments who are uh that are
still like i miss the anime zone when
are you going to bring back the anime
zone reviews and i'm just like dude i
killed off reviews for like a [ __ ]
reason okay yes i have changed in that
sense i'm not doing anime yeah i'm not
doing anime zone reviews anymore i mean
people still ask me for my [ __ ] let's
plays i'm like
but then i also get annoyed at content
creators that like whine at their
audience all the goddamn time right
they're like oh why are you complaining
you don't like the new videos it's like
well it's it's
you need to go out your way and make
something yeah it's different you can't
expect your audience to just follow suit
and like yeah it's it's up to you yeah
sometimes you just have to be like just
screw what the audience thinks if this
is what makes you happy you do that i
hate i hate youtubers that sit there and
make videos whining that they're not
doing well yeah i'm like get over it
you you if you do something else if you
change something or you're doing you're
not making like stuff that is keeping up
with the times yeah that's on you i
believe yeah that that is part of the
job that you signed up for exactly yeah
yeah you should know this you know
in if you're a doctor you have to keep
learning the new medical practices you
can't you can't go doing [ __ ] you know
like in the 1960s are you a covenant
here's some leeches but you know what i
mean like we don't you can't do that the
only difference is there's regulations
yeah and you're forced to do it yeah but
god imagine if there wasn't people
people would never [ __ ] update their
thing yeah and then the reason why they
do it is because it's to the detriment
of everyone else around us yeah the
problem is with youtube it's not an
instrument of anyone else if a content
creator falls off there are tons more
you know what i mean it is up to you to
make sure that you are making stuff you
are updated
when my channel falls off there can be
plenty of uh [ __ ] uh kirby enthusiasm
memes of this section of the podcast
i'll i'll you know it's if i stop trying
to change that's on me if i don't want
to do that anymore i understand my
favorite comments i get though is like
it's not even the you've changed or the
i like the old content better it's the
you've fallen off
comments
yeah you're irrelevant now and i'm like
what because you personally don't like
my stuff now i'm subtly irrelevant in
the grand scheme of things it's like
dude yeah i mean yeah there's people who
are not gonna like what you know and
that's fine like i'm not trying to
appeal to everybody yeah like if you
like if you don't like it
that's cool dude there's literally
thousands of content creators you could
go and watch yeah that's not strange
it's strange i
i don't really know what's your opinion
gone tell me your opinion my opinion on
changing
what the [ __ ] you want our opinion on
yeah
no i mean like
for me like changing changing is part of
part of our job
and life i think you should change as a
person yeah absolutely when i when i go
back and see my friends from school if
they're exactly the same as they were in
school i'm like that's a red flag why
yeah but some people don't change you
know
did you notice that going back i did i
did and i don't
i i
don't give a [ __ ] if they haven't that's
on them it's i think it's like oh
that's odd like nothing has changed your
point of view in life in five years like
nothing has made you think different not
none of your experiences have changed
who you are okay fair enough yeah but
then i don't want them to be like oh
you've changed it's like
yes i have get over it well yeah of
course i've changed i
i moved to a foreign country and i have
no idea what's going on after the
[ __ ] time and i barely know how to
communicate with my taxi driver yeah of
course i've changed yeah i'm fighting
for my life man yeah exactly
exactly no because i feel like that just
says a lot of us about us as people
because i'm i'm constantly looking for
change i'm like same sorry i i am like
uncomfortable when things stay the same
for too long nothing that's that's why
that's why you're [ __ ] i get scared
when [ __ ] starts to get monotonous right
like which which is kind of makes
youtube my perfect job because i i never
want to stay still i i'm constantly
wanting to change not just like bmw just
like in in korea but in like my own life
like that's why i've moved countries so
many [ __ ] times i still don't know
why i want to settle down yet because
i'm like scared to like stay in one
place for too long you know i just like
you know that's just that's just me as a
person i i constantly like changing my
life and i'm not saying if
if you are the type of person who
doesn't change and stays comfortable in
one place there's nothing inherently
wrong with that but all i ask is you
don't judge
us for changing changing for changing as
well and you know there are some people
in some people who i was mates with back
back in the day that i have less in
common with now and that's just part of
me having to accept that i have changed
and we have less in common we're not
going to push our values on you guys so
you know just don't do this
yeah
except for drip you should buy drips
well i'll give my opinion you have to
take it but absolutely i'm very brash
with my opinion i know that yeah
yeah i'm not gonna cry over you not
agreeing with me like i don't care i i
do get annoyed people completely
misinterpret what i'm saying yes that
doesn't yeah yes actually i'm like how
did the [ __ ] did you get that like yeah
what yeah
you're you're starting a completely
different argument
speaking of going to your hometown and
see if people have changed right i do
have i do have a
i do have a funny story about someone
who i met in my university town that has
definitely changed in a way that i
didn't imagine okay okay so what
happened is i went to see some of my
mates who are living in bristol right
now which was my
my city where i went to university i
went to university of bristol
um and so we're at this club right
and um we we meet we meet a guy there
and this guy um who i wasn't you know i
wasn't very close to him in university
but uh
word on the street was he was the type
of guy who if you needed certain
substances
that was the guy to call right
okay and um so
you know i'm just you know having a
casual chat and uh he asked me what i'm
doing and i was like oh i started
talking about japan i saw start talking
about uh being a youtuber living in
japan and stuff like that
and he goes oh i do something about
japan now and i'm like what the [ __ ] do
you do now what what is this person it's
like like to to preface this is a guy
who applied to love island once right he
is
he is not the kind of guy who i would
expect has
any interest
in japan at all right and he goes oh
yeah like um i uh i deal in ideal
pokemon cards now i was like
[ __ ] off
what what what what is this and he's
like how i'm like how are you getting
pokemon cards i was like oh i love
pokemon i've always loved it and i was
like how are you getting pokemon cards
and i'm like gone
i've got
contacts and i'm just like
why why did you have to make it sound
like that
i'm sorry
and so and so and so he takes me he
takes me over to one side right
he's just like
you're gone come on come here come here
look
i've got a good deal if you're
interested in pokemon go i was just like
i was just like what what
i was like you're taking the piss you're
taking the piss and it's like mate i
just sent off i just sent off a shiny
mewtwo it got graded nine grade nine
shiny mewtwo man first edition it can be
yours i'm selling it but i'll give you
i'll give you a good deal i'll give you
a good deal and i'm just like this is
the weirdest [ __ ] offshoot of
breaking bad i've ever seen
we got a great
and so yeah
like like so this this this guy went
through a complete career change
apparently and is now as a and is now
dealing pokemon cards i've got contacts
and game freak
just pulls out a bunch of business cards
the whole weirdest aspect of this whole
pokemon card was what it was that people
were sending cards
their cards
for logan paul to open um
why why
so that they could be in the video
there's some kind of like modern cucking
that i'm not aware of where like you
don't get enjoyment of opening your own
things now you have to sound to someone
else who can open them but better it's
like a [ __ ] it's like a form of
voyage like oh it's like oh he's opening
that pokemon card just the way i'd like
that's my dick
oh it's a shiny bulbasaur oh like what
is this what what [ __ ] gear are we in
where we don't get enjoyment it's like
it's like well i'd go and buy a bunch of
gacha and i make joey log in my account
and do it because he does it better than
i mean that also is a thing yeah yeah it
got gotten all these pools for me
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure there's like a bunch of
like ginseng youtubers who get they too
yeah they get like tech doesn't like
yeah like take like pulls for other
players it's like what i mean i feel
like it's just like living vicariously
through this one person right because i
guess
with pokemon cards it feels like a weird
extra step where you would send these
like extremely valuable cards to be
opened like yeah do they
come back to the past yeah they come
back to the person
i i think it's i i think i think i kind
of get it because it's kind of like
sharing you like like like this it's all
about the experience right because
you're you're sharing the experience
with say your favorite content creator
because you know there's there's a
difference you know there's there is a
difference doing it yourself and like
having to freak out by yourself and like
doing it as like a group as was like
okay
it kind of makes sense i guess it just
feels like this weird kind of what year
are we in
it's a bit of an experience some people
just don't want to open up their own
things anymore i'm gonna invite gone
over to open up my [ __ ] dyson vacuum
cleaner just so i can get the true
experience of how it does watch him take
off he's how a dyson should be on box
because god will do it better than me
isn't it weird like like okay i
understand it's a shared experience but
it's weird yeah
it is strange right it is strange it's a
bit strange i don't think it's strange i
i i would you do it would you send off
your cards for someone else to open no
but i would if if i'm like say opening
like a rare pack i'd want my boys in
there i'd be like i wouldn't want to do
it by myself i want to like i want to
like share the experience right boys
look it's it's just like part of the fun
is is the shared experience of just
doing this exciting thing you know but
when does it not become your thing it's
it's not your thing anymore it's someone
else's yeah what do you mean if you send
your cards off to logan paul to open up
do they still does he send them back
yeah no no
but i think it's like there's a massive
difference it's like you being cut out
right yeah there's a massive difference
between like you gathering your friends
to do it in front of your friends and
then sending your cards to someone that
you don't know
don't know
if you give me the cards yeah that's it
yeah yeah i mean i mean it's not with
extra steps but like
you're sharing that with like say one of
the biggest content creators on the
platform right so it's like so it's like
yep
dude do this role for me joey i can't i
can't you do it joey you do the problem
is that like the majority of like if
they're like streaming on twitch the
majority of the chat isn't going to be
like oh this is the card that was sent
by this person holy [ __ ] i guess i kind
of get it now that you say it like that
i do kind of understand that you could
get more enjoyment i've seen other
people react to your thing yeah yeah
but it is just strange isn't it what
what level of consumerism are we on
right now this is we buy things for
ourselves for someone else to open for
yeah what what what level is this like
just make sure to send it back
capitalism is this this is what they're
going to use in like com other communist
societies be like look look at it they
don't even buy their own stuff anymore
they buy it for someone else to open
isn't it weird look at that
it is like
i think okay i kind of get it now but
it's strange yeah it's a bit weird
you have to admit objectively it sounds
bizarre i mean you you can make anything
sound weird if you like put it in a
tried way try it
try it do it
do it right now give an example
but like i mean like
i mean like
that's that's kind of like the same kind
of argument when let's play starts to
get popular right oh it's like it's it's
it's a bit weird you know i mean you're
kind of just watching someone play a
video game and they're not even good at
the video game well okay i would argue
with that one though it's not like i'm
buying a physical copy of the game yeah
and then sending it to the line
i don't have a copy anymore
yeah and then i watch you play it yeah
it's it's not like i'm sending a game to
the let's play and then they're like
just after you finish it just give me
back the game
people do buy games yeah streamers but
then they normally do that because they
want to get they want to see them have
the experience that they had
so
it's it's it's all about the shared
experience right and then that's i guess
i guess i do understand the feeling it's
just
it does seem strange to me that this
even was a thought at first glance
someone was like i'm going to send my
cards
to logan paul
[Music]
it's like i think this is the way you
say in the sentence
it's akin to like being cucked in my
mind
i won't get as much satisfaction out of
doing this as i would watching someone
else do this yeah
it is kind of more satisfying right i
mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're telling us
you're into your own [ __ ] that's cool
dude i mean like for example with gacha
it is like a lot more fun to pull on
stream it comes back to gadgets it does
always come back to catch a ride but i
mean that's that's kind of peak
entertainment 2021 i mean that's that's
what pokemon cards are right yeah it's
just physical
it's just physical gotcha right yeah
this is the loot box oh gee yeah
so it's it's a lot of fun to do with
your mates like every time i remember
when we were like addicted to art nights
every time every time joey was in the
office he was like i'm gonna do a pool
and we're like oh
let's let's see what he gets and it's
it's a lot more fun to do with mates
because if you don't get it then your
mates will be like haha you're a [ __ ]
idiot
right right but it's not like um you're
buying packs for joey to paul because
you get the cards back so it's but let's
say yeah yeah i guess you do
yeah yeah yeah but i guess like the
equivalence of that is like i'm gonna
give you a hundred bucks to pull on
knock knocks but once you finish the
pause i need you to send me the hundred
bucks back yeah it's like that's a
little weird
i mean it's more like you're just giving
the phone to another person joe joey you
do the pull for me you don't i trust
your schedule like giving your
significant other to someone else for
one evening
that you can view while you sit back and
enjoy the show
i'm not crazy right with this comparison
no i get what you're calling me yeah
from yeah but it's just now that i think
about it it is
not as weird
as i initially thought
okay that's weird as that is in it
is it weird that we don't find that
weird anymore let me let me show you
another idea okay okay
so you know you know like you watch
movies and animes
and stuff like that so i know you're
gonna say all right right so so [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that like imagine instead of
watching a two-hour movie you could
watch
three blokes sitting on a set just
arguing about chicken breasts and
chicken thighs how's that found how's
that sound sounds like quality contact
that's cool that's called
choices i have one question okay why
how do i sign up for that
i i suppose what would you cata why do
you think why do you think trash taste
is successful
[Laughter]
what do you think a
is yeah
why would someone go and watch us
instead of watching a movie which is
just
objectively better entertainment
i could give like a really deep answer
now that is just like i i feel like i'm
ready for the truth bomb i feel like
with with the whole shared experience
thing we're talking about a lot of
people would now crave kind of like that
feeling of
like
a relationship or like a closeness of
someone and people a lot of people can
feel that parasocially by for example
sending their fa their cards to their
favorite streamers or sending some money
for their favorite gadget streamers to
uh
to pull or just watching three blokes
three friends talk for two hours you
know you get that feeling that you're
connected with someone that you have
that feeling of connection even though
that connection isn't technically real
you know and i feel like a lot of
content
nowadays especially with the younger
generation
is got like a lot of the most
a lot of the most successful streamers
and a lot of the most successful content
creators are people who can accurately
represent that feeling of a close
connection a parasocial relationship
let's say um see that was that was that
was that was my deep answer um i'm 14
and this is deep
my meme answer is just it's just
threeplex chang [ __ ]
it's just funny it's just fun in it
i guess because we we don't you know we
didn't strive to have that right we just
make we just talk
but it's always much deeper we do it for
our own self-satisfaction
we just want to make a show we just
checked i mean we didn't try for that it
just happened by complete life there's
also like i guess the whole
i watched a video
by what's his name glink is it his name
clink did a video about only fans yeah
and the more not not the sexual side but
more so the power of social side where
yeah a lot of guys are on there because
they that's like the closest they feel
that they can get to a girlfriend yeah
yeah and that was really sad watching
that video because he had interviews
with people who are early fans
subscribers
you know and as much as we mean monolith
fans and and all that that whole uh
thing and you know earlier we mentioned
the whole dancing woman on tick-tock i
do feel very sorry for these guys like a
lot of them that
feel that they have no other choice or
there is no other choice for them yeah
just to life circumstances or maybe
whatever's going on maybe they're too
busy you know it's uh you know and it it
is it isn't just the stereotypical guys
you think who are doing stuff like that
who consume that you know sometimes
these people just have no time they're
very successful yeah and they have too
much money but uh the one thing that uh
you don't have is time which is uh and
uh the ability to go and make friends
yeah
especially this day yeah
it is hard like a lot of people are
lonely yeah it's especially during the
times of the pandemic as well that's
like only kind of just
extrapolate
extrapolated that's
yeah exacerbated you know i feel sorry
you know uh for a lot of guys um
obviously as a as a male myself
it's one of those things where you can't
really openly talk about being lonely
it's quite difficult to do it you know
and um
it's often hard to just reach out to
friends and be like hey man i'm not
gonna lie ah i'm just lonely man you
want to hang out like it's yeah it's
really hard to do that and that's right
it's that whole stigma of like macho
insecurity right
i always want to try and dispel that and
and be honest and
try and be open with my how my emotions
and what i'm feeling just so that
hopefully that other people can be more
open with it as well like i feel like
when you're a public figure it's kind of
your responsibility to
uh try and improve the uh
understanding of uh topics like that i
think gentlemen you're allowed to feel
emotions yeah yeah yeah bro i know how
so you know because you know more often
than not there is a lot of um
toxic masculinity and pride
that men have you're supposed to be
successful and provide and and uh you
know
basically not be a fuck-up right
and this pressures are [ __ ] difficult
man
i feel like a lot of guys end up pushing
up pushing a lot of friends away because
they're so focused on trying to
not be a failure
yeah and i feel like especially with
guys it's hard to talk about it's hard
to talk about something negative like i
remember yeah i remember like i remember
when we went back uh to see all our
mates and we uh we add that to airbnb
we're all caught up i remember like
going into like a conversation like a
deep conversation that some of uh some
of our guy mates were having at that
time i remember sitting down uh on the
table and uh
like uh one of our mates was talking
about you know going through therapy for
one of one of the things that they went
through right and you know uh more more
and more people started sitting sitting
in and then started
sharing their stories about how they
also were go through something rough
especially during covert and they had to
like seek therapy about it and then
eventually we just had these this whole
table this group of guys and i was just
like wait a minute
has anyone here not been to therapy
we look around and nobody puts their
hands up and i was like so wait so
everyone here has been to therapy and i
was just like
how have we never talked about this
before we've known each other for like
four years it's a shame thing right yeah
people got a lot of guys feel
shame admitting that they they have any
of those problems yeah exactly and i'm
just like if something should be
normalized and not be ashamed of frowned
upon it's just it's this you know it's
admitting that you have a problem and
you're seeking help free and it's it's
like i feel like especially especially
in england and especially in asian
culture it is very much frowned upon to
like say hey i went to therapy or i
talked to someone and i was just like
because it like the mentality is that if
you go to therapy then you are you're
inherently trying to fix something about
yourself you're there isn't something
inherently wrong about yourself but i
think people don't want to admit that
there's something wrong yeah i'm not
going to just avoid it yeah i think
that's that's that's that's absolutely
[ __ ] you know just speaking like
trying trying to keep like a healthy
like
a good mental health is not it's not
something that should be frowned upon
you know and i feel like america and
this are like leagues ahead of other
cultures and just accepting this
and
gender doesn't stop you from being sad
like if you're sad it doesn't matter
what you identify as if you're sad
you're sad and if you need to talk about
it you need to talk about it like yeah
it sucks because the
the male suicide rate is so high yeah
man like [ __ ] i got so so sad thinking
about it well male depression rate is so
high yeah like no one [ __ ] talks
about this thing right when i was in uh
in my first year of living in london
looking back i could easily tell you i
was depressed but at the time i didn't
know i didn't know why i was miserable i
didn't think i i i was like i have no
reason to be sad so i'm not sad i'm just
that's because he had no one to talk
about yeah yeah yeah bad mood but i also
didn't even
because i hadn't been educated on it no
one even told me that that was like who
tells you what depression feels like
yeah how do you learn that
i didn't know what it was yeah i didn't
understand what it was and only now when
i look back and i think oh i had like
all the [ __ ] the trademarks of
depression like i didn't want to hang
out with anyone but i also was lonely
yeah
and and there's tons of other catch-22
right it's like it's it's and normally
it's being your own worst enemy um but i
didn't understand that and and i'm very
very lucky that i managed to just get
out of it on my own yeah and that now
i'm much better and i think it was a
whole slew of reasons of why i i don't
feel that way anymore uh mainly like
just life reasons changing yeah but i i
wish that i had had more education on it
in school like in wales it was never
[ __ ] brought up depression was for
people who are crazy that was not what
healthy people have with normal jobs and
wives you know you can't be sad if you
have a job and a wife yeah yeah exactly
you've got a 50-inch plasma screen tv
you can't be depressed
depression depression is people who kill
people yeah that's what it was like you
know like i i'm obviously exaggerating
but yeah and i feel at school as well
like it's harder to take seriously
because of the environment that you're
in oh yeah yeah yeah i was just
miserable in school anyway
like i
yeah it's it's it's really difficult and
it's really uncomfortable thing to think
about yeah and there are times in my
life where i'm like oh yeah i'm near
certain
i was like miserable and
very very unhealthily so very
self-destructive but i just didn't
recognize it and i didn't know why yes
the main reason is like
why yeah yeah no one not most of the
time nothing makes you depressed it
happens yeah and i feel like you know
it's going back to what you're taught in
school it's just like oh the you know
seeking help therapy those are for the
crazy people yeah exactly you know it's
just like you
you know what you don't want to be
associated with the crazies with some
something you know and it's just like
that's just not how real life is at all
a lot of people have a lot of issues and
like some on varying skills but there's
nothing wrong with just [ __ ] talking
to someone professional about it there's
nothing wrong with seeking help yeah
like you know
when it when you're when you've had it
for an extended period of time
um i didn't know i was like well this is
just normal this is how i've always felt
i don't know i don't know anything else
this is
what do you mean that's when it starts
to get scary yeah yeah because that's
all i like for a while that was like how
i just felt all the time so i was like
oh no well it was nothing to complain
about this is how it was because because
your memory is very good at letting you
forget things yeah over a year so you
you very much forget how it was yeah um
you'll be you could be you'd be
surprised how easy it is for your mind
to just accept things
now you can get used to a lot of things
and it's it's [ __ ] scary how you can
just get used to like a lot of
like a toxic period in your life or like
a really bad period in your life and
your mind just like accepts that as norm
and if you forget that life could be
better that's you that not everyone
should feel this way yeah and
unfortunately our mind has a terrible
way of
coping with situations we don't like
yeah and our brain is [ __ ] amazing at
like
hiding [ __ ] from us so yeah so for a
long time i didn't know why i was saying
that
it was but i i couldn't figure it out
like yeah the brain is very good at just
like [ __ ] putting on the emergency
handbrake sometimes and being like don't
think this it's really good like
that that little little brain is really
good at distracting you little [ __ ] that
boy yeah oh yeah i i implore you to
think about it more and uh
don't be ashamed to get help don't be
[ __ ] ashamed of the dude don't don't
be and don't be ashamed to talk to it
about your to to talk with your close
mates about it because that's the
biggest thing that's very very blessed
that i have good friends right yeah and
if your mates don't take it seriously
then you know that's something that's
telling off your mates that's probably
not your mates that's that's telling
yeah that is telling because because of
you know i i realized then that i was
lucky enough to have mates you know
including you guys who i can talk to
anything about you know and it's not
just here it's back home as well and i'm
just like damn i got a pretty good group
of friends i feel pretty blessed right
now you know i'm obviously not going to
bring it up every goddamn conversation
no no no no you can you can bring it up
it was a [ __ ] bro moment when i'm
just like i'm glad we're [ __ ] talking
about this now man yeah but you know i
want all my friends to feel like they
they can they can come to me yeah yeah
and trust and be like listen man i'm
really struggling yeah yeah let's let's
let's do this let's sit down let's talk
about it whatever you need man let's
figure it out like let's let's do it
like i want you to be happy mates don't
want to see mates being sad oh man
you know the one thing that i've learned
as i'm getting older god forbid i'm 25
and i'm saying that [ __ ] but it is it is
it is
i noticed it is harder to make friends
it gets it gets more difficult to make
good friends yeah because everyone's
doing [ __ ] yeah
you know and i feel at that point as
well everyone already has their like
established friends have your own friend
groups and stuff and you know and it's
it's it's hard man yeah it's time
for man i remember when i was growing up
everyone's just like time is your most
valuable resource and i'm just like fine
what does that mean [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
give give give [ __ ] off give me opening
give me a million dollars and we'll see
how much time isn't gonna buy me a
mcdonald's meal okay
shut up dad logan is opening my pokemon
yeah it really started to hit me when uh
i just wanted to hang out with sydney
and now she's like got her own career
and everything we literally had to like
schedule a date yeah we've never had to
do before and i'm just like what we have
to book out time to spend time with each
other you have to pencil in a date i
have to pencil in time to spend time
with my significant other and i'm just
like what a good time what is this what
is this
yeah it is very weird yeah and um it's
like time management is a thing that you
have to learn as you're growing older as
well and
like also you just don't have as much
energy as you did before like it's like
your energy levels do like go down
because your patience for [ __ ] just
like just it
it dwindles you know i'm like i have
zero of that now yeah yeah just like
immediately i'm like i'm not gonna waste
time on this because now i know how
valuable my time is like i finally
understand that time is your most
precious value i know right finally
understood after all the [ __ ] i went
down like oh this is what this means and
it's not even like oh i could use be
using this time to make money no no
you're not i mean i could be using this
time to be happy i could be using this
time to hang out with my homies to play
some games yeah like like anything but
this [ __ ] like if there's something
that makes me angry nowadays it's
something that wastes my [ __ ] time
i'm literally like literally like i
don't have many pet peeves but if i feel
if i do something and i feel like i
could have been i could have used that
hour doing something else yeah i i i
that's the biggest thing that makes me
angry man i could have been like i could
have been playing like a good [ __ ]
game could have like been hanging out
with my homies yeah could have been
doing anything yeah anything anything to
make me happier than where i am now
japanese government building
thousand hours of waiting
oh my god i've had a question in my mind
that's been haunting me uh-huh okay
this guy
came out of the toilet right right in
the public toilet and he flushed the
toilet as he left when did you flush the
toilet uh because i do you do you like
because yeah well it depends what you're
doing you've done it you've done number
two right okay number two right yep you
have your you know so you stand up right
you now have two options you can start
buckling your belt putting it back up
putting you know getting that already or
you can flush the toilet which one you
do first while standing up
yeah because there are some people who
flush while they sit that ain't right
that is
that's
just typhooning your [ __ ] of [ __ ]
water like that's terrible the only
circumstance upon which you are allowed
and i will i will i will give the pass
to be able to flush the toilet while
still sitting on it yeah you know that
smell is so goddamn bad that you your
cheeks are the only thing keeping it in
okay i personally stand up first when i
flush you know obviously yeah because
you're you're a human being i'm not now
do you then right so let's say you've
unbuckled right your pants because
you're obviously you've run back with
them i don't know why this has been
burning on my mind because this men did
it he clearly right
he clearly got up did his pants and then
flush the toilet and left
right yeah
which one do you first sometimes i i
immediately i just closed the thing
flush and then start doing up my pants i
why is that i buckle up my pants first i
buckle up my pants first then flush them
yeah yeah why am i the weird one what
happened in my childhood because it's
like it's weird like the way you do it
is weird because it's that means you're
literally standing there flushing the
toilet with your pants down
so like i'm like this right pants are
here i'll i'll simulate it i'll simulate
it okay
so it's like this right yeah right i'm
like okay close the lid flush and then i
do this while it's flashing but your
pants are down right
no well then that's exactly the same
thing because when i'm okay right when
i'm like this right right i come up and
then as i'm getting up i kind of like
pull it up
to the point of like like it's there but
i just got to zip it up and do the belt
you know you understand what i mean you
understand what i mean right no
i don't i don't i fail to see the
difference what's the difference what do
you mean like what's the difference
between the way you do it in the way i
do it so so when i stand up i love how
conversations gone to [ __ ] already i
just i just saw this happen
we just had like the deepest [ __ ]
therapy sessions
this has been on my mind for like three
days no i i saw someone do it i'm gonna
need a therapy session off this
conversation all right so
so i stand up right
and i picture it right anyone with any
pants is doing this you pull it up right
yeah now there is a moment where you can
now decide to well your pants up you're
standing up your hands are now free for
a moment you can choose to then move
your hands to the zipper and the belt to
fully close your pants or you can flush
the toilet okay i choose to i choose to
flush oh i choose to do my pants first
yeah and then flash yeah like how do we
how do we develop these behaviors that's
what i want to know what makes us why do
we why do we do this it ain't that deep
bro
it's illegal
it's because i would like before i flush
the flush right is
the is is the signal that i have
finished everything yeah like because
because here's the thing here's the
thing right you're sometimes sometimes
you're in a public toilet right i
[ __ ] hate the people who like flush
like sometimes sometimes you're [ __ ]
desperate you're just like
god i need to go [ __ ] it now and you're
waiting you're waiting for something to
come out of the toilets and you hear the
flush
right you hear the flush are you just
like all right they're coming out and
they stay in there for another five
[ __ ] minutes doing god knows what are
you like the flush is like the flush is
like a pavlovian enough yeah
it's like you hear the flush it's all
ready to shift yeah yeah it just doesn't
happen it's just it's just like if you
flush you better be coming out of that
toilet though okay
if you flush there must be a 10 second
window you have to get out the toilet
yeah you're signaling the end of your
yeah that's why i want to be fully ready
to get out the moment i flushed a
[ __ ] sprint man
i don't want to keep the guy waiting i'm
just wondering is there something in my
in my brain that makes me decide to do
that first
you're just trolling aren't you i don't
know like i do wonder this yeah like
i'm gonna take my time i was like
psychoanalyze like little things i do
and i wonder like why do i do like that
why do i do those things i don't know
maybe it's like a maybe it's a habit you
had since you were a kid maybe yeah like
maybe when did you notice this
i noticed that this guy immediately left
after he flushed and i thought to myself
oh hold on i do like to flush and then
take a moment and just kind of oh you're
the one person i would [ __ ] hate to
be yeah
you are that [ __ ] who's like the
total 25 minutes the total time doesn't
change right but the perception of time
changes exactly i don't know if to you
it's ten seconds after you've flushed it
to us it's ten minutes but overall it's
the same time i'm spending in there so
it doesn't matter you're gonna get in
there so to me to me if you don't leave
the toilet by the time the flush is
finished then you are taking too long
yeah
that is the etiquette right that is that
is the yeti i agree right okay do you
also have we covered this on channel
before i don't know if we have how do
you poop in public bathrooms do you care
about that i mean
yeah we haven't yeah i remember in
school i was i was the weird one because
i didn't mind pooping in the toilets but
i also was like what am i gonna do you
[ __ ] animal yeah like like to me to
me it is like a last resort
yeah i've seen crime scenes less messy
though so i i i one thing i do remember
now that we're talking about this
when i was back in uh london i went to i
needed the toilet before i got my train
in houston station now one thing about
houston station in london is that it's
probably one of the dirtier train
stations i'd say yeah it's definitely
one of the the rougher looking stations
it doesn't look as nice as the train
stations aren't already dirty well i
mean king's cross is pretty nice
looks pretty fancy
i'd say i know one thing one thing i
noticed after going back was like
compared to japan everything's done
train stations
train stations suck in the uk yeah yeah
you don't find out what platform your
train is on in houston until like five
minutes before yeah so everyone's just
standing there and then when the thing
comes up everyone's rushing okay and
it's like why don't you just tell me it
before and then but i guess there's some
system on their end where they don't
know yeah
it's stupid they should know they should
figure this [ __ ] out come on figure it
out [ __ ] figure it out um but so i
went to the toilet in houston station
and this ship was absolute war crimes
i'm sure some geneva conventions are
broken in this toilet yeah there was no
no toilet seat
in this toilet what was just the ball it
was just the ball
i've seen that before and i thought
there must be a mistake that's already
nice i i refused to go in this one it
was very busy someone would steal the
lid or something
who knows
um i go to the next one it's the same
thing i go to the next one and then now
there is now there is a toilet seat
there it is
but there is like
it is it is like something has happened
in here yeah not only is the smell
abhorrent but like there is like four
pieces of toilet tissue left and its
that horrible horrible system of like
one tissue that they ration out that you
have to like you have to pull out 50 to
get one wipe with anyway it's like
what's wrong with you people i get it
that you don't need to take a [ __ ]
another role i understand that but why
do you have to make it such a small
amount you know what i mean like and
it's always like half a ply yeah it's
like if i held this up i could see
through it and navigate perfectly in a
car in a car right so there's this
toilet seat oh it's terrible and then
not only that when you leave it i hate
when public bathrooms do this they don't
have any soap anywhere yeah no soap
nowhere to dry your hands and it's like
are you you're just telling me not to
drop you're not telling you're just
asking me not to wash my hands yeah yeah
right like so i go there i do the
obligatory put water on my hands and
leave and i feel dirty still my hands
are wet i can't drive i'm depressed not
only was there [ __ ] stains all over this
thing that stunk yeah it's terrible
shocking how do they not keep these
toilets clean i don't understand it's
just not getting paid enough are they
you have one job
and it's literally to keep them clean i
don't think there's anything else you
need to do in the toilets well the thing
is that like that's why i don't [ __ ] in
public you know that
this is why
yeah
i mean it's it's there is a big
difference between the toilets the
toilets the toilets in japan versus the
toilets in the uk right i mean i mean as
as you mentioned last week the first
thing you noticed is things are a lot
dirtier in the uk well after you've been
living in japan for like this long right
yeah oh
go for it go for it sorry i i went to
this toilet in uh covent garden yeah so
i went to a coffee shop right coffee
shop was too small they didn't have
their own toilet so they used a toilet
uh in coffin garden that was connected
to the church okay and it was
30 pence to enter it's about 50 cents
maybe yeah and um oh that's right you
guys charged for toilets oh god this
toilet was it was like it was like
entering some
uh sewer level in a video game going
down these stairs so he was in the
stairs down used to go on the street
level you have to go down this really
old looking 1800s architecture you get
this this this out like this um kind of
cove looking thing it's just it's this
archway right
and again it looks like from something
out of the 1800s that was never replaced
yeah yeah it's amazing great
architecture yeah but this is then this
is turn style and it is is the most
disgusting color of orange green
wall that you've ever seen and the
lights are flickering and uh yeah sounds
like you're about to enter a dark souls
level and i'm near certain i'm the only
person on earth who actually paid to get
in yeah because the moment i got it
the moment i got in two guys just jumped
after me yeah so i go in here right
and only one of the stalls is open
so i go in there and i need to do my
business now unfortunately there was
only like two sheets of toilet roll left
so i was already it was already a bad
time hard mode
so my ass never quite felt clean so i
was constantly i was also struggling
with that every single day yeah i
definitely felt my ass was not clean
uh they're genuine you joke but i i
walked around many days thinking like
holy [ __ ] i need to bring a portable
today yeah yeah um so i'm in this thing
right
i'm hearing noises from the two stalls
oh my god that's not a big deal it's not
a big deal and then this guy drops a can
that kind of ominously rolls into my
store yeah right and it's a can of
guinness
and i kind of like kick it back and i'm
like here you go he's like cheers and
i'm like
i'm like
okay
and he's like it's a nice day today in
it and i'm like
you talking to me
i'm in the middle of the [ __ ] like
me he's like who else would i be talking
to and i'm like i don't know i'm like
why why i'm just confused i'm like yeah
yeah it's nice so i go out
and these two guys come out one of
them's homeless and one of them just
looks like i don't know who this guy is
he doesn't look homeless yeah but one of
the other guys is clearly homeless
because his stall was just had his like
sleeping bag in it oh jesus and i was
like what on earth is going on and and
the guy was like you didn't actually pay
for it did you and i was like yeah i did
and he was like oh you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then washed his hands and left and
then the other guy just stared at me and
i was like this is the most
uncomfortable toilet experience i've had
i was like
i thought it was gonna die yeah and then
i was like okay i'm just gonna go
through and i just worked the turd style
which have to press like some kind of
emergency meeting butterness to get out
yeah horrible the kicking back the
guinness can just sounds like an event
in a game it was weird this is how you
activate the store
i heard something drop and then it had
that really ominous noise of rolling
yeah and it came over and i was like
kicking it like
take it back i don't [ __ ]
if there's one place i don't want to
have a conversation it's on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] right yeah especially not not
not you know maybe if we're in some kind
of
ritz-carlton-esque toilet where it's
it's amazing hand towels you know yeah
you know fancy place there's no tissues
there's towels there's a towel there's a
pile of towels to wash your hands
and then i'm like actually how my day is
how is it i'm just enjoying the fine
selection of towels here and soaps and
moisture milks you know it's great that
then talk to me yeah
but when we're in
the sketchiest toilet in london no thank
you and there's a horrible student next
to you i didn't know this guy had his
whole whole setup in there i was like oh
my god that's i mean like i don't know i
don't know if that's okay but i mean i'm
glad you've got some accommodation yeah
but like [ __ ] me jesus christ scary yeah
i just didn't know why they're gonna
call me a [ __ ] well i paid for it i
tried to be a good citizen you know
someone has to stock the toilet paper
how else are they going to afford it is
that the only like bad public toilet
stories that has happened to you because
like i swear yeah when i went back oh
when you went back yeah because that's
that's why that's why you just don't
[ __ ] in public
in the uk at least well in japan okay no
no it's not no it's not in japan uh
there is a common phenomenon in japan uh
if you go to some places at night there
is a big thing where dudes try and watch
your your your pee pee in japan have you
seen those videos
on twitter you've never seen them no
there's loads of videos right we're not
joking
no
in certain areas uh i think they are
very more likely to happen there's
videos of dudes like jacking off in
urinals like right next to other guys
just seen this
oh my god i mean i've heard stories
about this i've seen i've i've seen this
on twitter i'm not surprised like the
first stories about this i've never had
a lot of stories of like dudes like
you know looking at it and yeah stopping
looking at it and that's
apparently somewhat common in japan i
mean i'm not surprised at all this is
japan i mean it could be common it is
also you know i mean uh
when you when you kind of uh treat your
treat gay people kind of harshly here
yeah and stuff like that i guess they
have no choice don't feel comfortable
but they're like oh yeah
it's self it's still strange
i've had friends who's happened to here
really yeah well they've just started
like pulling it out and going at it
oh my god
i've heard i'm sorry
i mean there are some sketchy parts in
shinjuku
surprise i have seen i have seen there
has been a couple of instances where i
have seen dudes in public jacking it
yeah they do it it's it's not weird it's
not always it's not unusual to see yeah
unfortunately it's not unusual to see
and it's uh it's definitely scarring
yeah you know something like a jaunty
stroll through shinjuku and then it's
like oh
just jacking in the alleyway we don't
normally hang out at those like kind of
like establishments so it doesn't really
surprise me in that area but like yeah i
mean most public toilets in japan are
like cleaner than like most people's
private toilets it's [ __ ] ridiculous
you're like like the the concept of
clean public toilets didn't exist in my
mind until i went to japan i'm just like
wait
i've seen some really [ __ ] dirty ones
in japan oh yeah occasionally there is
something it occasionally happens but
normally you never average normally you
never see clean public toilets
especially in england and especially
especially in [ __ ] thailand as well
like my god you know where southeast
asia okay
wait wait wait wait i actually realized
going back why i don't like bidets right
and uh it's because i realized oh i've
grown up my entire life with bidets
because southeast asia have their own
bidets right but okay because
but in southeast asia we have this thing
that which we call a bidet but it's not
a [ __ ] bidet it's a hose all right so
so if you guys uncivilized are you going
to south east asia no in japan you you
have
you have a toshiba system that measures
the moisture of your ass yeah to deliver
the perfect blessing the reason the
reason i hate the feeling of bidets is
because my entire life i've had like
southeast asian bidets which is just
like every toilet has like this hose
right
you know you know how in the days in
japan it's like this [ __ ] precision
yeah but obviously precision sniper that
snipes your [ __ ] balls
you have this [ __ ] hose for your
shotgun yeah it's like a [ __ ] shotgun
that you shotgun your entire [ __ ]
anus how do you use this if you're like
you know you're
are you on the toilet yeah you're on the
top you're on the toilet so so you have
to like put the hose between your legs
some places some places in europe have
that as well you have the hose between
your legs the smaller one on the it's
like a small little baby
yeah yeah which is so
whenever you go to weird
public police like what the [ __ ] is this
where is it always
i don't wanna i don't wanna be reminded
of a theme park where i'm going to the
toilet i don't want that and so so like
a lot of public toilets in southeast
asia you see the toilet seat and it's
wet and it's not wet from piss it's just
wet from the [ __ ] bidet right and so
that's why that's why i like i i think
i've ingrained that into my mind to be
like yeah that feeling of water on your
ass that's bad feeling you know what
i've tried to i've okay i like how we've
just managed to go from deep to [ __ ]
again
i apologize
i'm sure we'll run out of topics to talk
about with this eventually um i i
in japan sometimes you do come across
the old style toilets of japanese
toilets yeah have you ever used them the
waski toilet well i'll talk about it
yeah so which is just aka a hole in the
ground and you squat over it and you
just do it yeah now i have used it one
time
and i just could not get over the
feeling that i was just kind of dropping
something that was just gonna splash
everywhere yeah yeah and i could not get
over that feeling
i was squatting real low but i i i just
i couldn't and i did not enjoy it it was
not fun
what i hate about those because i've had
to use that plenty of times as well in
southeast asia especially like
especially if you're on a long drive
yeah like if you if you need to do your
business every public toilet is that
hole in the ground if if it came to it
and the only option i had is that a hole
in the ground yeah i'm shooting i'm
[ __ ] the hole in the ground yeah
yeah it's gonna happen
but if i can i will obviously go for the
the premium warm ass bidet blasting
temperature moistening experience any
day of the week
the thing that makes me most
uncomfortable is like
with a normal toilet there's the seat
and the seat is like a safety barrier
nothing penetrates this barrier right so
i don't like that i can miss yeah
i've never missed the toilet i don't
miss i don't i hate it i thought you
[ __ ] i have to play [ __ ] like mini
golf with it but like if you if you miss
the hole then he's that he's going to
clean that [ __ ] up right what am i gonna
do i'll just kick it in
do i get any toilet paper and scoop it
in what happens does anyone know who's
there is there a correct you just don't
miss dude
you don't mind i have gone i have gone
25 years or probably like 23. without
missing
i'm very happy to keep my streak alive
yeah i don't want to even attempt to
miss and also i just like sitting down
i'm lazy yeah yeah i don't like that you
know you you're propping yourself up
with your own legs because if you don't
then and you fall over i don't do
exercise
supposedly it's it's supposed to be
better to squat like just like
that's what they say it's like it's less
likely you're going to get hemorrhoids
and shields it's better for me to stop
at mcdonald's but i still [ __ ] do it
right
a lot of things that are better for me
why did we get on this tour i'm so sorry
this is my fault
he was on my mind okay and i thought i
didn't bring it up was it on your mind
this entire time it's been on mine for
like three days
i saw the men do it and i woke up
thinking about it i'm also very used to
just like [ __ ] in a hole in the
ground from like going camping in
australia because like yeah well you
know
we have long drops and there's just like
it's literally just no that's just wales
you just do that yeah
no but when you're camping you have no
choice yeah exactly it's just a hole in
the ground but it's like it's not like a
like a shallow hole in the ground it's
like a real [ __ ] deep hole oh really
we i should just dig when we just go
camping we dig a tiny hole and just fill
it up oh no no like there was ones where
it's like your [ __ ] what are you doing
no no no it's like ones that are built
into the campsite
oh like in a cabin oh they made an
outhouse yeah like an outhouse
yeah but it's like a wooden log cabin
and you walk in and it's just a hole in
there that's an outhouse and you like
put your torch in it and it's like you
can't see the bottom that's a [ __ ]
house yeah that's an outhouse yeah
exactly
and uh yeah i i had to do those actually
those are the worst okay this is the
worst toilet experience of my life
mm-hmm i'm gonna say that
all right so picture it you're skiing
you have those damn [ __ ] ski boots on
yeah okay
all right and so
have you ever have you worn ski boots
actually
it
is to have precision movement in the ski
boots yeah right you walk like a roblox
right right so you do you you walk like
you're in roblox
um so uh the only option at this
particular skiing place for some reason
was a porta potty
okay can you imagine a porta-potty in
ski boots it doesn't work
right yeah yeah because you need to sit
down you gotta aim yourself you gotta
have room to close the door it's
horrible right
that was bad enough that it was a porta
potty i thought oh my god i gotta use a
porta potty and ski thing and ski boots
oh my god
i get in this porta potty i think it was
in um might have been bulgaria yeah i
get in this porta potty i don't know how
this has happened there is there is
toilet roll with [ __ ] on it on the roof
on the sides
on every it it looks like some kind of
that someone is trying to do use like
ancient talismans of [ __ ] on this porta
potty to to get spirits away it is
i i i immediately threw up when i got in
there yeah because i i still needed to
go so i i stuck with it but right after
i was done i threw up it was so
disgusting i'd never seen anything like
it it was it was almost like a trap that
they'd put there for tourists it was
like [ __ ] you tourists coming to our
place it was horrible man you go into
this thing it's tiny right you can
barely sit there your ski boots barely
fit in so your knees are touching the
door that also has [ __ ] on them i don't
know how this happened to this day i
still don't know why this i apologize
viewers you have to listen to this it's
disgusting it was oh god but that's what
my toilets are like that that's why
that's why i i flush the toilet yeah
that's why that's why i never shot like
when i was in high school too because
like my high school because i went to an
all boys school right so obviously
there's going to be some some [ __ ] afoot
like in places
where they're like
there's going to be [ __ ] in places where
they shouldn't be [ __ ] that was always
the pranks wasn't it it was always the
pranks and i'm like guys
like we're we're not animals people
shooting in urinals yeah like oh dude
i don't think there was ever a day where
i went to the urinal there wasn't [ __ ]
in it like it was actually disgusting
australia is a different country yeah
i'm like even in southeast asia yeah
just like yeah it was it was [ __ ]
gross i'm like yeah
wow wow humans so disgusting i don't
know why why why can we not [ __ ] [ __ ]
properly apparently
toilet training is always we've had 2
000 years to get this right yeah and
we're still we're still
we're only one step ahead we're still
sitting in the hole in the ground god
damn it how do we always talk about
[ __ ] how crazy i really i didn't
want to i really didn't want to i wanted
to get it i'm sorry for anyone like
[ __ ] eating like yeah i i i like
where did they get away from it i didn't
want to trust this to be the [ __ ]
podcast but it also it is my mind
i'm done there's no more [ __ ] now i
promise you won't talk about [ __ ] for 10
episodes
[Applause]
i ain't gonna make that promise
[Applause]
of such uncivilized manners on this
podcast we are a civilized podcast yeah
with two australians uh one australian
two breads yeah should be civilized
[Laughter]
that's what we are right
but you know who shits normally oh my
god here we go our patrons oh look at
them
amazing they definitely don't because
they watch us
they they definitely [ __ ] hate bonus
points if you're listening to this on
the toilet
that's the that's the yeah that's the
true trust experience right shout out to
all the southeast asians who knows about
the hose bidet who grew up [ __ ] this
that's that shit's still like [ __ ]
like gone whenever he needs to increase
his popularity yeah he's fellow hey
southeast asians
oh am i right southeast asia
i'm just trying to bring the southeast
asian culture to the main street people
would need to know what it's like okay
hello southeast asians hello
how are you but hey if you'd like to
support the show then go to patreon.com
also follow us on twitter send us your
means on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on spotify wow but
uh yeah
again i love how trash tastes the only
show where we can go from deep self-help
conversation to how do you [ __ ]
yeah i i feel i feel like i feel like we
need to have like our like say monthly
or bi-monthly therapy session with the
boys and then we're like okay and then
immediately follow it off
and it's just like all right out of our
system great back to poop
[Laughter]
god i'm sorry that was really poor
timing of me that's all right
well thank you patrons and everyone else
watching bye guys i guess bye
[Music]
you